[Musique]
je tenais d'abord à préciser les propos
que j'ai pu avoir dans une interview de
france inter qui est pas vraiment une
interview mais des propos qui ont été
sortis du contexte et je tenais parce
que je sais que certains d'entre vous
ont été vexés ont été choqués par les
propos qui ont été les miens et je
tenais à préciser le contexte dans
lequel je les ai prononcés
j'ai ressenti un moment un acharnement
médiatique un acharnement politique et
j'ai eu l'impression qu'un certain
nombre de personnes ont pu se servir des
institutions notre pays à des fins
politiques et médiatiques
j'ai servi aux institutions de mon pays
depuis l'âge de 18 ans en intégrant la
réserve opérationnelle de la gendarmerie
nationale j'ai toujours défendu les
institutions j'ai toujours respecté les
institutions et j'ai été élevé dans le
respect de ses institutions et je tenais
à vous dire que j'ai un profond respect
pour le cdh 1 j'ai un profond respect
pour les sénateurs et mon propos c'était
celui de d'avoir l'impression d'être
instrumentalisée à des fins politiques
il ya une chose sur lequel je voudrais
revenir j'ai été bien élevé j'ai un
profond regret pour le propos que j'ai
pu avoir à votre rencontre monsieur le
président parce que quelles que soient
les circonstances
quelle que soit la pression on s'en
prend pas aux âmes et j'ai le regret
d'avoir eu les propos qui ont été les
miens à votre encontre
pour le reste je voulais vous assurer de
mon respect total de l'institution des
institutions du sénat et des sénateurs
et vous présenter mes excuses monsieur
le président bas en ce qui concerne les
propos que j'ai pu avoir ce qu'on
n'attaque pas les hommes voilà les
quatre missions qui m'incombe et il y en
a une cinquième cape a été dit mais je
vous dirai à la fin la première c'est
l'organisation des déplacements
nationaux c'est à dire quand le
président se déplace
vous faites un certain nombre de
réunions préalables vous fait un certain
nombre de
préparatoire on appelle ça de
déplacement en préparatoire vous allez
avec le préfet son directeur de cabinet
le directeur départemental de la
sécurité publique
ça ce sont les locaux qui vous accueille
et vous partez avec un certain nombre de
personnes de l'elysée qui sont en charge
des services à l'elysée vous avez
l'intendant parce qu'il risque d'y avoir
un dîner un cocktail vous avez le
service de presse vous avez le chef du j
espère vous avez le protocole quand il
ya des personnalités étrangères
et vous votre rôle parce que vous êtes à
un niveau puisqu'il faut bien préciser
aussi qu'est-ce que c'est la chefferie
de cabinet c'est assez flou pour les
gens et je le conçois à l'elysée il ya
deux types de choses il ya le cabinet
politique qui avec les conseillers les
chargés de mission et vous avez les
services qui sont dans la mise en oeuvre
de ce qui a été décidé au point de vue
politique
donc celui qui a autorité sur l'autre
c'est le politique qui a autorité sur
les services jusqu'à preuve du contraire
c'est pas l'intendant qui va décider
s'il va faire 30 repas ou 80 repas il
fait en fonction de ce qui a été décidé
politiquement par le conseiller en
charge
si demain vous avez un cocktail sur la
thématique agriculture par exemple à
l'elysée dans lequel le président
souhaite inviter un certain nombre de
responsables syndicaux de responsables
agricoles etc
il va vous dire voilà on va faire
quelque chose avec un dîner un cocktail
vous allez recevoir la consigne
politique du haut du conseiller en
charge de l'agriculture et ensuite vous
allez mener une réunion avec les
différents services et il y aura le
commandement militaire
il y aura le cuisinier ira l'intendant y
aura le service de presse et vous allez
leur dire voilà ce qui a été décidé
ça c'est le rôle de la chefferie de
cabinet c'est le coeur du réacteur en
terme de logistique et d'organisation et
je vais répondre à la question monsieur
je vais répondre mais il faut comprendre
le contexte est donc vous animer une
réunion dans laquelle il ya plusieurs
personnes et vouloir expliquer voilà ce
qui attend attendu de vous il va y avoir
80 personnes donc il faut prévoir 80
repas monsieur le commandant militaire
le général il va y avoir 80 personnes
qui vont arriver le au mieux par le 55
où vous allez décider par un autre
endroit parce que voulait pas que ça
soit filmé et peu importe
est ce que au moment où je parle en
général je suis dans une fonction de
sécurité au même titre que quand je
parle à l'intendant au chef cuisinier je
suis pas cuisiner moi même ni
superintendant de l'elysée donc quand
vous êtes dans des fonctions la
chefferie de cabinet vous êtes dans des
fonctions transverses vous êtes dans des
fonctions où vous êtes amené à parler et
au chef du gspr et aux commandants
militaires et vous êtes là pour donner
le but à atteindre
les moyens employés par le commandant
militaire les moyens employés par le
chef du j'espère c'est pas vous qui
j'explique par soit un déplacement au
colonel lavergne qui est maintenant en
général tu dois mettre des barrières ici
ou quatre là bas c'est pas ça mon but
c'est de lui dire voilà l'idée c'est
qu'on fasse une arrivée propre parce que
vous êtes une sorte de metteur en scène
vous êtes une sorte de chef d'orchestre
vous êtes sous l'autorité du chef de
cabinet le rôle du chef de cabinet et de
la chefferie de cabinet il est très
clair c'est l'organisation générale la
coordination générale il est le chef
d'orchestre des déplacements et des
événements du palais et il est également
le metteur en scène
si je peux me permettre de parler ainsi
et pour être répondre manière très
claire j'avais quatre missions à
l'elysée ma première mission était
l'organisation des déplacements
nationaux dans le cadre de ce que je
viens de vous expliquer la force que
vous en aviez déjà connaissance il est l
organisation d événements au palais dans
le cadre de ce que je viens de vous
expliquer la également dont vous avez
connaissance il était le cadre
l'organisation et je vais employer le
terme parce que ce qu'on appelle les
déplacements privés du président de la
république je pourrais m'en expliquer si
vous avez des questions là-dessus et il
était dans une tasse dans une tâche
pardon donc on l'a appelée coordination
des services de sécurité
la coordination des services de sécurité
je pense vous avoir expliqué le par mon
parcours j'ai une petite connaissance du
domaine de la sécurité il consistait pas
à être le chef de la sécurité de
l'elysée il consistait à conduire un
certain nombre de réunions de réflexion
souvent si vous prenez le colonel
lavergne qui est maintenant en général
qui a besoin de 12 voitures
supplémentaires par exemple pour son
parc automobile
s'il n'a pas un appui politique si le
cabinet n'aide pas c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne c'est le cabinet ne l'aide
pas il pourra aller demander 12 voitures
au ministère de l'intérieur
il sera tout seul face au ministère de
l'intérieur et c'est souvent ce qui se
passe donc par exemple j'avais en charge
le renouvellement du parc automobile de
l'elysée parce qu'à un moment vous êtes
vous fait des réunions un autre niveau
que deux chefs de service administration
centrale vous faites une réunion un
niveau cabinet c'est à dire le cabinet
du président de la république saisi le
cabinet du ministre l'intérieur parce
qu'il a besoin de moyens supplémentaires
voilà c'était c'était pas une pour pour
répondre très précisément ce n'était pas
une fonction opérationnelle de sécurité
c'était une fonction administrative
je voulais vous demander quel était
votre fonction par rapport aux
déplacements privés du président de la
république
ceux ci étaient donc votre fonction si
j'entends bien ce que vous dites ne
relevait pas de la sécurité ou de la
police en conséquence vous n'étiez pas
armés alors pour être très précis sur
l'histoire du port d'armes j'ai entendu
absolument tout et je sais que c'est pas
quelque chose d'habituel
ça peut poser question j'ai fait une
demande à titre personnel d'autorisation
de port d'armes pour des motifs de
défense et de sécurité personnelle parce
que quand vous êtes dans des fonctions à
la présidence de la république ou
pendant la campagne présidentielle vous
êtes exposés vous même et on est tout
sauf un jeu qu'à moi de mon point de vue
on est exposé on passe dans les médias
vous êtes identifié quand vous habitez
dans le même endroit depuis huit ans il
peut vous arriver quelque chose donc
j'ai fait une demande pour ma sécurité
personnelle je crois savoir qu un nombre
important de personnes ayant travaillé à
l'elysée se sont déjà vus délivrer des
autorisations de port d'armes
je pense par exemple je vais citer
sûrement j'espère qu'il ne m'en voudra
pas mais monsieur michel charasse
lorsqu'il était collaborateur de
françois mitterrand il disposait d'une
autorisation de port d'armes est ce que
monsieur michel charasse était le garde
du corps de françois mitterrand je ne le
crois pas un certain nombre d'autres
sous la présidence chirac par exemple il
y a eu des collaborateurs du président
qui ont pu disposer d'une autorisation
de port d'armes
il ya un certain nombre de
parlementaires qui dispose d'une
autorisation de port d'armes ça fait pas
deux des gardes du corps des autres
parlementaires
et tout ça pour vous dire que une
autorisation de port d'armes c'est
quelque chose de très rare
le ministère de l'intérieur les délivre
au compte gouttes en l'occurrence il ya
eu un refus mais pour des motifs
administratifs
parce que ma demande ma deuxième demande
de port d'armes au moment où je rentre
en fonctions à l'elysée
elle est basée administrativement sur
une première demande donc ce sont mes
fonctions de directeur de la sûreté de
la sécurité dans marche donc cesser jugé
pas recevable par la dlp agit c'est ce
que expliquait alors en substance
monsieur stéphane fratacci c'est que la
dlp agi juge que comme j'ai pas
renouveler une port d'armes en ma
qualité de collaborateur du président la
république et 10 non sur le principe ce
qui est normal
ce que doit y avoir un dossier
administratif car et complète c'est ce
qu'il veut pas dire qu'il a pas de
menace et je rentrerai pas dans les
détails
voilà
[Musique]
monsieur il s'agit dans ce faire juste
un petit astre fait excuser vous en prie
je vous y danser monsieur benalla nous
pouvons tout un tendre mais il y a une
réalité ce sont les visas les attendus
de la décision du préfet de police
elle elle ne dit pas monsieur b nana
pour sa sécurité personnelle a demandé
un port d'armes
et comme il a les qualifications
nécessaires de lui accordons dit
monsieur benalla est chargé d'une
mission de police dans le cadre de son
action de coordination de la sécurité de
la présidence de la république avec les
forces militaires et le gspr
alors il a bien fallu que la demande
comporte une description de cette
fonction de police pour que le préfet de
police qui n'invente rien puisse s'y
référer et d'autre part je laisse de
côté les allégations que vous avez pu
avancer sur des personnes qui auraient
eu des permis de port d'armes ou
d'autres peut-être à l'elysée qui en
aurait aujourd'hui mais convenait tout
de même qu' il ne suffit pas d'être
collaborateurs du président de la
république pour se trouver dans une
insécurité tels que cela justifie une
demande de port d'armes
je veux juste relever ces points donc je
vous demande très simplement de
m'expliquer pourquoi au préfet de police
on a dit une chose et pourquoi
aujourd'hui vous dites une autre chose
alors pour répondre encore de manière
très précise
je n'ai pas rédigé mon arrêté
d'autorisation de port d'armes cet
arrêté a été rédigé par un service qui
s'appelle la direction de la police
générale et qui a essayé de faire
rentrer mon cas qui n'est pas un cas
conformes dans les clous d'ailleurs il
est très imprécis sur mes fonctions
parce qu'ils expliquent la coordination
entre les forces militaires et le gspr
les forces militaires je ne sais pas ce
que c'est moi je pense que c'est le
commandement militaire du palais puisque
vous nous avez expliqué vous même cette
fonction de coordination des services de
sécurité monsieur loches
nous l'a révélé alors qu'il ne nous
avait pas été précisée dans nos
premières auditions
et qui dit vous dites il comportait la
coordination du commandement militaire
du palais et du gspr tout à fait et donc
pour répondre précisément je sais pas ce
que le seul interlocuteur que j'ai eu
sur cette autorisation de port d'armes
c'est patrick strzoda qui est dit on va
faire les choses dans les règles et on a
fait les choses dans les règles
il a saisi la préfecture de police de
l'étude du dossier
ensuite qu'une administration prennent
des considérants je crois d'ailleurs que
la considérant sur la menace terroriste
qui est précisées dans l'arrêté que
personne ne dit rien sur un certain
nombre de menaces
elle est précisé dans un alinéa de
l'arrêter et donc c'est pas forcément
mes fonctions de collaborateurs du
président l'a plus que c'est qu'il y
avait d'autres menaces dans lequel je ne
rentrerai pas dans le détail mais c'est
précisé sur cet arrêté patrick strzoda
n'est dictée en rien s'est arrêté aux
services de la direction de la police
générale
car si je croirais patrick strzoda a dit
voilà il ya alexandre qui est dans cette
situation là qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
est-ce que vous pouvez le faire ce que
vous pouvez pas le faire et la
préfecture de police a répondu
favorablement et des gens qui sont des
administratifs des juristes ont pris un
certain nombre de considérants pour
pouvoir attribuer de manière légale
réglementaire une autorisation de port
d'armes le sait la mission de police
elle fait référence à un arrêté qui leur
permet de me délivrer cette autorisation
alors est-ce que excusez moi le terme
c'est bancal juridiquement ou pas je ne
sais pas moi même je suis pas un expert
des arrêtés de port d'armes
je dis simplement que la préfecture de
police
après enquête administrative savoir s'il
y avait bien bien-fondé quant à la
demande
deuxième chose cet arrêté intervient en
septembre en octobre de fin septembre ou
début octobre de mémoire et donc je suis
un interlocuteur connu de la préfecture
de police et par là quand ma présence en
là pendant la campagne présidentielle et
par ma présence sur les déplacements du
président de la république
donc il ya sûrement eu un certain nombre
de démarches administratives internes à
la préfecture de police
sur la base de la requête de patrick
strzoda clés à aucun cas dits alexandrie
des policiers ou alexandre il s'occupe
les termes sont inexacts donc c'est un
certain nombre de considérants
il prend en compte le principal c'est à
dire la menace qui pouvait peser à un
moment sur moi et donc ils ont délivré
un document qui me permettait de
justifier à l'occasion desquelles je
portais mon arme et s'est précisée dans
mes missions et je tiens à répondre à la
question tu vas être posée après mais
dans vos missions donc mes missions
c'est quoi c'est l'organisation des
déplacements etc
mais la mission quand vous êtes à
cabinet du président de la république
elle est permanente
elle s'arrête pas à la mission donc
quand vous quand je rentrais chez moi je
rentrais chez moi avec mon arbre
influence englobe 43 sur moi jusqu'à mon
domicile
voilà donc monsieur ben ali vous
comprenez que vous mais dit on a voulu
faire les choses en règle et la
préfecture de police
énoncer des motivations qui permettait
aux pandas d'être légal tout à fait est
ce qu'on ne peut pas en déduire que si
vous n'aviez pas eu la mission de police
relevé par le préfet de police
mais si vous aviez fait la demande
uniquement en disant c'est pour ma
sécurité personnelle
normalement elle également le permis de
port d'armes aurait dû vous être refusé
alors c'est pas tout à fait exact comme
il l'a été au ministère de l'intérieur à
deux reprises sur ce que georges
verreault préciser encore il a été
refusé à deux reprises par le ministère
de l'intérieur sur des motifs
administratifs sur des problèmes non pas
de deux d'opportunité ou pas même si un
moment sur le premier port d'armes est
intervenue une décision de frédéric
auréal chef du sdl b qui n'a pas
souhaité que je puisse porter une arme
pendant cette campagne présidentielle
sur le deuxième la deuxième demande
c'est un problème purement administratif
parce que je n'avais pas renouveler en
l'état en faisant état de mes nouvelles
fonctions la demande et on avait relancé
la première demande ce qui a été refusé
par la drpj
mais c'est sûr je souhaite terminer si
les immigrés venant sur l'autorisation
de port d'armes la mission de police
n'est pas un préalable à la délivrance
de l'autorisation de port d'armes
il est prévu par les textes de code de
la sécurité intérieure en espèces que
peut se voir délivrer tout fonctionnaire
exposés à des risques dans le cadre de
ses fonctions
une autorisation de port d'armes par le
préfet territorialement compétent en
l'espèce c'est le cas on a considéré la
préfecture de police
à considérer que mes fonctions étaient
exposés et m'a délivré une autorisation
de port d'armes sur la base du code de
la sécurité intérieure et j'étais donc
quand je dis fonctionnaires ces
fonctionnaires ou agents publics
j'étais agent public finalement je vois
que vous ne connaissez pas si mal les
règles d'attribution et port d'armes
alors monsieur le président en sueur
merci monsieur le président encore
beaucoup de questions
e il nous a été refusé d'avoir accès aux
documents suivants la demande faite non
pas par vous même mais comme vous l'avez
dit dans un second temps par monsieur le
directeur de cabinet de bord dame
il est étrange qu'on nous ait refusé de
la connaissance de ce document est ce
que vous avez ce document alors je pense
qu'il n'existe pas de documents vous
n'êtes pas sans savoir que le directeur
de cabinet du président la république
est en lien avec tous les préfets il a
dû décrocher son téléphone et demande à
michel delpech de voir si dans les
règles il était possible de m'attribuer
une autorisation
je me considérais que ce port d'armes
qui a été refusé deux fois pour des
raisons administratives par le ministère
de l'intérieur a été attribué par
monsieur yann drouet que nous allons
recevoir sur un coup de téléphone à
l'oreille tu demandes écrites alors je
pense que c'est pas la procédure en
l'espèce c'est que dans un premier temps
il ya une personne qui appelle une autre
personne et qui demande
voilà quelle situation on est confronté
ce que vous pouvez regarder si c'est
possible si ça rentre dans les clous des
ans patrick strzoda a quelqu'un d'assez
prudent et de trait dans les règles et
c'est quelqu'un de très droit c'est
quelqu'un de très droit il n'a exercé
aucune pression ni téléphonique n'est
simplement il a appelé préfet de police
en lui disant voilà la situation dans
laquelle et alexandre qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire et le préfet de police par la
suite a saisi ses services son cabinet
dans un premier temps donc son chef de
cabinet ian drew et et yann drouet a
saisi la direction de la police générale
qui a écrit cet arrêté est donc parler
avant d'écrire cet art était d'ailleurs
qui m'a demandé un certain nombre de
documents justificatifs permettant de
prouver un et d'ailleurs ils sont
mentionnés il me semble dans l'arrêté
que j'avais les capacités à porter une
arme
que je n'étais pas soumis à quelconque
problème d'ordre psychologique mais
dites donc j'ai fourni un certain nombre
de documents
mais les échanges des cris se font entre
l'intéressé et les services pas entre le
préfet de police et son direct et le
directeur de cabinet du président la
république qui s'appelle il va enfin je
pense qu'il n'a pas le temps déjà de
pouvoir écrire un courrier il ya une
saisie administrative officiel entre
l'intéressé et le service aux services
en l'occurrence la direction la police
générale son quatrième bureau de mémoire
pourquoi aviez-vous jugé utile d'obtenir
la possibilité d'accéder à tout lieu au
sein de l'assemblée nationale j'ai bien
vu que vous n'aviez pas sollicité cela
pour le sénat l'acte mais pourquoi
était-il nécessaire que vous puissiez
accéder y compris à l'hémicycle alors
badens à l'intérieur mais juste à
l'entrée
j'en étais je dispose alors ça peut
paraître complètement irréaliste mais
surréaliste ce que je peux dire mais
c'est la réalité depuis que j'ai
travaillé au parti socialiste
j'ai été bénévoles et salariés au parti
socialiste fait les deux j'ai bénéficié
d'un badge d'accès dans ce qu'on appelle
les collaborateurs occasionnels
collaborateurs bénévoles
je citerai pas les noms des deux députés
qu'il nous avait accordée mais quand
vous avez ce type de badges vous avez
accès à la bibliothèque
c'est là où j'ai préparé mes examens de
master et vous avez accès à la salle de
sport que j'ai continuer d'emprunter
quand vous êtes collaborateur du
président la république et vous
sollicitez ce un badge de manière
automatique les services administratifs
de l'assemblée nationale vous délivre un
match collaborateurs d'emmanuel macron
il est écrit dessus avec un h pour parce
que c'est le plus haut
niveau d'accès mais ce n'est pas une
demande qui analyse et c'est un process
automatique c'est à dire que vous avez
le conseiller politique ou le
secrétariat du conseiller politique qui
fait la demande de badge
je les dis je reconnais c'était un
caprice personnel c'est pourtant ce jeu
continue à la salle de sports la
bibliothèque
voilà bon mais il n'y avait pas de
demande particulière avoir accès à toute
l'assemblée
d'ailleurs je ne sais pas ce que
j'aurais fait dans l'hémicycle ma tête
est inconnu par un certain nombre de
parlementaires jeu mais si vous avez
bien conscient ce dossier pénal a que
l'attribution de ce type de carte n'est
pas destiné à permettre aux
bénéficiaires d'aller faire du sport
l'exclusion de toute nécessité de
service dans les relations avec les
parlementaires
alors pour être très précis où je des
associations au sein de l'assemblée
nationale auquel je payais ma cotisation
et qui sont ouvertes à n'importe quel
citoyen et qui sont animés non pas par
des administratifs de l'assemblée
nationale menée par des gens extérieurs
il ya un certain nombre de clubs de
sport ya le club de rugby par exemple de
l'assemblée nationale et à club de golf
de l'assemblée nationale et qui est
ouvert un certain nombre de personnes
qui sont des collaborateurs ou pas au
même titre que la présidence de la
république et son association sportive
est ouvert aux extérieurs
donc je n'y allais pas pour y accéder a
qu'à voir un accès privilégié
l'assemblée nationale mais parce que au
même titre qu'au sénat vous avez aussi
une association sportive et culturelle
qui est ouverte à des gens extérieurs au
sénat que ce soit vos amis où que ce
soit des gens extérieurs tout simplement
tout à l'heure vous avez confirmé que la
sanction voulait perceviez comme une
rétrogradation vous ai même dit une
humiliation après qu'on vous ait informé
que vous ne cordeau ne riez plus les
voyages du président vous n'aviez donc
plus aucune mission et le chef de
cabinet nous a dit que vous avez des
missions de synchronisation de cortège
pour l'essentiel après sanctions vous
allez continuer à conduire une voiture
qui était badgés police a continué à
porter une arme c'est ma première
question
la seconde c'est la suite de ce cas vous
a dit monsieur canard on a été quelques
uns ici est membre du gouvernement
l'épaule droite et l'épaule gauche d'un
ministre d'un président d'un premier
ministre c'est toujours les de
l'officier de sécurité et dans les
photos on vous voit comme étant dans ce
rôle physiquement je parle à dans les
photos
même quand le président ou un ministre
est approché par quelqu'un souvent
l'officier de sécurité sert d'interface
pour apporter les dossiers ou telle ou
telle question
donc ma question et c est moi qui ai
fréquenté beaucoup l'elysée matignon
ça a toujours été comme ça c'est donc un
changement de pratique comment vous
l'expliquez de la fonction d'un officier
de sécurité s'est pas de porter les
dossiers le manteau ou de passer des
messages à la personne qui le protège
c'est de le protéger c'est d'être
attentif c'est de regarder ce qui se
passe autour de lui la question ont
fonctionné dire je crois je parle sous
le contrôle de monsieur daubresse
si vous vous êtes dans une position
caractéristiques de la protection à
l'épaule ou et le garde du corps qui
fait la protection à l'épaule je pense
qu'on avait vu tous ces images il était
soit à droite si j'étais à gauche soit
gauche si j'étais à droite c'est visible
sur les images il n'y a pas de place
prédéfinis et je voulais expliquer tout
à l'heure simplement c'est que il faut
un moment comprendre que les officiers
de sécurité se sont pas les vallées des
personnes qui protège et donc ils sont
dans des fonctions de sécurité ils se
sont adaptés et je leur explique pas ce
que je pense pas avoir été clair tout à
l'heure je suis désolé c'est que ça
donnait ça a donné lieu à des
discussions entre le chef du j'espère et
le chef de cabinet sur la proximité
physique y compris du chef de cabinet
lors des déplacements du président de la
république monsieur benalla vos
compétences en matière de sécurité sont
incontestables
ce qui paraît moins vraisemblable c'est
qu'on nous dise que vous occupiez de
tout sauf de sécurité lors on en a parlé
il ya vos attitudes et gestes
professionnels
c'était des survivants se les mentions
de l'arrêté du préfet de police
octroyant le port dame qui fait
expressément référence à ça les
déclarations des syndicats nous parlant
de comportement autoritaire et déplacer
ou de relations exécrables que j'espère
alors vous contestez ses propos mais
vous avez quand même reconnu que vous
étiez considéré par eux un
extraterrestre j'en prends votre
expression ou comme ingénieur en termes
plus crus alors n'était ce pas parce que
justement vous ingérer dans leur champ
de compétence sur le port d'armes
vous n'avez pas été aussi clair même
qu'on nous l'a dit ici qui était jamais
dans les déplacements publics seulement
dans les déplacements privés alors
question précise sur les déplacements
privés où vous étiez armée était ce
parce que le j'espère était absent vous
avez expliqué même que président vous
d'un effectif léger où était son double
assurance et dans les déplacements
publics donniez vous d instruction ou
des ordres aux policiers et gendarmes
gradés ou non quand je dis qu'on me
qualifier d'extraterrestres jeu faisait
pas référence aux officiers de sécurité
du j'espère je faisais référence à un
certain nombre de personnes qui sont
dans l'administration sont des
administratifs pur jus et pour lequel
j'ai pas tout à fait le profil de
l'emploi
quand j'explique qu'il pouvait y avoir
des tensions avec eux c'est parce que je
suis un peu dans l'esprit du président
c'est que quand on me demande de faire
quelque chose je le fais je vais un peu
jusqu'au bout et parfois vous attirer
des inimités de gens qui vous explique
que ça fait 40 ans qu'on fait comme ça
et qu'on vous a pas attendu pour changer
les choses
bah ça peut créer des tensions parfois
et quand vous faites pas partie du club
excusez moi de l'expression et ben on
vous le reproche on vous le fait sentir
en tout cas d'une manière différente
c'était là dessus que il y avait cette
affaire de j'avais dit qualifiés qui ont
qualifié d' extraterrestes pardon sur
les déplacements privés le port d'armes
il ya toujours eu toujours eu est le
seul responsable de la sécurité du
président de la république c'est le
général lavernhe et il ya toujours eu
des éléments du j'espère en permanence
avec le président de la république il
s'est jamais retrouvé seul ni avec un
officier de sécurité ni avec moi il ya
toujours eu un dispositif complet jamais
je veux juste y ait jamais eu de trou
dans la raquette de la sécurité du
président de la république a toujours eu
le dispositif même parfois quand il
était minimum il ya toujours eu la
sécurité autour du président la
république officiel toujours eu les
forces de police ou de gendarmerie avec
lui est-ce que je portais mon arme comme
une assurance td assurance pour moi même
je reste président la république je
rentre pas chez lui
je rentre chez moi après quand j'ai fini
donc je la portais pour moi même pour ma
sécurité personnelle encore une fois je
le répète
monsieur benalla à vous écouter nous
avons le sentiment qu'il est très
difficile de ne pas franchir la ligne de
crête est étroite entre les fonctions de
coordination d'organisations d'un côté
et les fonctions de policier de sécurité
de l'autre vous dites ne pas avoir
exercé des missions de police et de
sécurité
mais nous avons des témoignages de
journalistes dans deux circonstances qui
atteste que vous auriez et des images
parfois que vous auriez procédé des
fouilles et un contrôle d'identité
c'est à la mongie en décembre 2017 et à
marseille à une notification de mise en
garde à vue d'un photographe fait ce que
vous pouvez nous répondre sur cette
question je n'ai jamais fouillé ou
contrôler l'identité d'un journaliste
quand vous êtes je vais vous prendre un
exemple assez descriptive a décidé de
comprendre vous allez mieux comprendre
la fonction quand on était en guyane il
ya des gens qui ont attaqué la
préfecture je réponds à la question
madame d'un contrat s'il vous plaît
juste je réponds à la question vous avez
l'autorité administrative le secrétaire
général de la préfecture en l'occurrence
qui est à côté de vous et vous avez 500
personnes qui attaquent les gendarmes
qui attaquent les policiers qui
attaquent la préfecture il se tourne
vers vous et ils vous demandent
qu'est-ce qu'on fait
je sais que ce que je dis est pas
politiquement correct mais c'est la
réalité l'autorité administrative ne
prendra aucune décision sans l'aval de
l'autorité politique et donc vous
représentez le cabinet du président de
la république donc si un moment où vous
demande est ce que je dois prendre tels
moyens ou si vous devez orienter la
manière dont vous voyez les choses
eh ben vous le faites et quand vous avez
des gens qui atteignent à la vie privée
du président de la république qui le
harcèle sur son lieu de vacances
vous prenez en responsabilité des
décisions qui sont celles de dire aux
policiers du j'espère qu'ils ne savent
pas s'ils doivent le faire ou pas le
faire quand la personne a franchi les
limites est rentré sur une propriété
privée pour photographier
madame ou monsieur en maillot de bain et
ben vous expliquer aux policiers il n'a
pas le faire mais quand on fait du
politiquement correct on dit non mais
j'ai pas donné l'ordre d'aller
interpeller
il a commis un délit il a été contrôlé
par les policiers il a été placé en
garde à vue par un commissaire de police
sa part alexandre ménard c'est bien là
on va s'en tenir là pour cette réponse
j'attire l'attention des collègues que
si monsieur benalla avait procédé
lui-même à des contrôles d'identité ou à
des fouilles se serait défait
potentiellement délictueux tout à fait
qu'il n'appartient pas à notre
commission dans lequel parlementaire de
l'amener à s'exprimer sur des délits
qu'ils auraient éventuellement commis ce
qui n'est pas le cas à celui non plus
loin dans
cette recherche de précisions vous avez
fait une réponse générale les gens
retiendront donc cette cette réponse
générale eux lors de vos travaux au sein
du commandement militaire de l'elysée
aviez-vous à traiter pour l'émission que
vous exerciez avec monsieur alexandre
benalla alors avec alexandre benalla que
je ne voyais pas tous les jours parce
qu'il a fait du tout le même emploi du
temps que moi on se côtoyait on se
voyait on se croisait mais par exemple
je n'ai aucun souvenir d'avoir eu le
temps de déjeuner avec lui un midi lors
de toutes mes journées puisque j'étais
moi même j'étais moi même assez occupé
est lui aussi dans mais c'est arrivé
bien sûr mais on n'a jamais eu le temps
même de déjeuner ensemble donc formation
était purement informel et amicales oui
parce qu'il n'ya pas de lien
hiérarchique au sein du palais entre lui
et moi je dépend entièrement du
commandement militaire et donc général
bio farina et donc de
d autres officiers kiné mais vous savez
et une bonne connaissance de monsieur
ben alla tout à fait nous nous
connaissons depuis 2009
alors est-ce que à votre avis parce que
vous savez nous posons beaucoup de
questions et nous recherchons vous savez
nous mêmes la vérité le plus possible de
nous approcher de la vérité de regarder
les dysfonctionnements qui ont lieu de
voir les propositions que nous pouvons
faire c'est notre travail est ce qu'à
votre avis
il exerçait des missions d'organisation
de déplacement exclusivement ou est-ce
qu'ils exerçaient des missions de police
et de sécurité
alors monsieur le sénateur je pense que
vous avez auditionné beaucoup de monde
très longue amant monsieur benalla ce
matin et qu'il a eu tout le loisir de
répondre à cette question
moi je me réserve le droit de ne pas y
répondre
très bien mais puisque vous le côtoyer
que vous le connaissiez vous savez
peut-être une idée sur la question j'ai
forcément is game hervé vous savez lire
la vérité jules je dis la vérité mais je
ne suis pas monsieur bénard je suis
monsieur kraz oui d'accord mais quand
vous avez une connaissance du sujet bien
sûr que je vous pose et vous pouvez
répondre en toute sincérité
ça me concerne en rien monsieur le
sénateur oui au fond monsieur mais je
crache vous vous estimez que de votre
balcon de l'endroit où vous étiez vous
ne pouviez pas apprécier la réalité de
la fonction de monsieur benalla je ne
connais pas sa fiche de poste je n'ai
pas lu son son contrat de travail donc
je ne vais pas me risquer à dire des
approximations très bien monsieur le
président est suédois d'insister vous
étiez à l'elysée vous le connaissiez
bien eux
vous pouvez nous dire si ce qu'il
faisait et on nous à vous savez on nous
a tout dit et donc nous devons
rechercher la vérité
on nous a présenté je l' ai déjà dit
plusieurs fois comme une sorte vous
savez de gentils organisateurs de
voyages comme dans une organisation qui
célèbre il est très gentil je vous le
confirme non mais je
je ne porte pas de jugement mois sur ce
sujet et voilà une information en tout
cas que vous nous avez donné on nous a
aussi on a eu des éléments qui ont
montré qu'ils avaient des fonctions de
sécurité à à commencer par le permis de
port d'armes
donc vous saviez bien les choses comme
vous ne pas vous dire je ne savais rien
vous savez bien que ce n'est pas vrai
monsieur le sénateur même si je sais
cette chose je ne vous y répondrait pas
très bien écoutez je prends acte de
votre réponse alors d'autres questions
madame jourda oui cette fois ci c'est
vraiment la dernière je voulais savoir
monsieur crasse dans ce au sein de cette
cellule du réserviste il y avait
d'autres salariés éventuellement la
république en marche et si c'est le cas
comment il était recruté s par votre
intermédiaire vous ont ils été
recommandée alors il n'y a pas dans
l'es14 de salariés de la république en
marche
en revanche il y a il y à un réserviste
que j'ai connus lors de la campagne et
qui connaissent en ma qualité de
réserviste m'a posé des questions m'a
dit c'est mon rêve depuis longtemps etc
etc
et comme c'est quelqu'un que j'ai eu
l'occasion de former à dijon et dont je
connais la droiture et j'ai pu apprécier
les qualités professionnelles pendant
cette formation je les jeux les
recommandés oui il a passé par contre
comme les autres l'entretien avec moi et
avec un autre officier et l'entretien
avec le général
il n'y a pas eu de il ya pas eu de passe
droit en aucun droit s'il avait été
mauvais il a été mauvais on prend pas le
risque de prendre quelqu'un qui est pas
le au maximum de ce qu'on exige parce
que on est quand même au palais de
l'elysée merci de ces premières réponses
monsieur grosdidier l'homme on est un
peu surpris est-ce que c'était sur une
pratique habituelle que le semaine alan
zach piqué tout à l'heure qu'il fallait
ouvrir presque à la société civile les
services de protection de la présidence
de la république
on pensait jusqu'à présent qu'on avait
l'élite des des plus professionnelles
des professionnels non pas parce que la
réserve de la gendarmerie n'est pas
parfaitement honorable on apprécie
beaucoup son intervention sur l'ensemble
des territoires mais parce qu'on est là
dans les missions les plus délicates qui
concerne ne le sommet de l'état alors
dire qu'ils qui a au départ manifester
cette volonté d'ouvrir à des moins
professionnel la protection de la
présence dans le public
et est-ce que ça concerne
essentiellement des sympathisants du
mouvement politique de majorité
présidentielle ou est ce que cette
pratique très ouverte sur un ensemble d
des réservistes de la gendarmerie
indépendamment de toute considération
partisane alors monsieur le sénateur
j'essayais pareil de faire une réponse
globale à toutes vos interrogations
il n'y a pas dans l'es14 de sympathie
face il y en a un que j'ai connu pendant
la campagne et c'est tout tous les
autres sont des gens que j'ai connus
soit lors de cet appel à volontariat qui
viennent du 1er régiment est captée déjà
des réservistes soit des gens que j'ai
recruté deux mois même pas que j'aie
prérecruter présélectionnés de moi même
lors de la préparation militaire de
gendarmerie et je leur ai pas demandé si
c'était adhérents marche
première question deuxième question vous
vous étonnez 2
la présence de réservistes donc au
palais de l'elysée en fait je vais pas
parler je ne suis pas je ne suis pas un
grand spécialiste des réserves
militaires
mais aujourd'hui l'état des forces
armées qu'elles soient terre air mer
gendarmerie nécessite l'emploi de
réservistes parce que on connaît les
difficultés
voilà on connaît les difficultés que vit
notre armée je pense que sans l'apport
de la réserve opérationnelle qu'elle
soit air-air mère gendarmerie elle
serait encore plus grande donc l'apport
de réservistes moi j'ai une très grande
part j'ai une très grande gêne plus
grande expérience de la départementale
puisque j'ai passé 13 ans je peux vous
dire que l'apport des réservistes est
absolument essentiel merci de votre
réponse madame benbassa merci monsieur
le président j'ai deux questions à vous
poser est l'une c'est la halle à propos
de la tribu oui à propos de
l'attribution de votre statut
d'observateur qui soulève des questions
puisque monsieur bruno roger petit alors
pour parole de l'elysée nous expliquer
que vous possédiez effectivement une
autorisation pour les observateurs
tandis que monsieur le général bio
farina a démenti cette information
comment expliquez vous ces différentes
versions et deuxièmement par curiosité
je voudrais savoir si vous êtes toujours
membre de la reine
et vu que les statuts de votre parti
stipulent que lorsque l'un de ses
adhérents comme un acte préjudiciable
aux mouvements sol celui ci doit être
entendu par une commission disciplinaire
interne de nombreux militants ont pas ce
processus déjà subi une procédure
d'exclusion
qu'en est il dans votre cas alors
attends pardon je vous prie de m'excuser
et je prie madame benbassa ne m'en
excuser aussi mais la question sur le
titre que vous pouviez avoir ou pas à
participer même en qualité d'observateur
au la présence policière
le 1er mai nous sommes convenus que
c'était trop proche de l'enquêté
judiciaire pour que vous ayez à répondre
à ce type de question mais vous devez en
revanche répondre à la deuxième question
de madame benbassa merci monsieur le
président c'est la réponse que je
m'apprêtais à faire madame la sénatrice
pour la deuxième question est ce que je
suis encore salarié de la raim non
puisque j'ai été licencié j'ai été
licencié le marais ce qu'on peut dire le
31 juillet parce que j'ai eu mon
entretien préalable à licenciement à 11
heures mais à huit heures du matin ils
étaient déjà annoncé que j'étais
licencié bon donc ça a été un peu un peu
baroque
concernant le fait que je sois toujours
militant je ne sais pas je reçois encore
des mails en tant qu'adhérent donc
j'imagine que oui
s'il décide de ne plus m'en voyez je ne
le serais plus je vous remercie
madame lherbier monsieur kraz quand eux
il ya une mission à pourvoir
y at il des feuilles de route bien
précise
y at il des rapports à rendre au terme
de toutes les missions en général alors
une mission de réserve se prévoit al
avance dans dans les meilleurs délais
possibles quand cela est possible mais
des fois ça peut être un peu plus rapide
toutes les missions font l'objet d'une
convocation on a un logiciel qui nous
permet de remplir en ligne
la réalité de cette mission qui doit
être validé par l'autorité d'emploi
parce que si on veut se faire payer
il faut qu'on puisse prouver qu'on a
bien réaliser cette mission
donc il ya des services de gestion qui
s'occupe de ça moi j'ai été notamment
je dépends des du 1er régiment
d'infanterie à nanterre donc c'est eux
qui gèrent et tout a été validé en temps
et en heure pas d'autres questions
mais si madame train de l'est merci
monsieur le président juste une
précision monsieur kraz on vous a posé
la question tout à l'heure qui était à
l'initiative de constituer cette
structure de réserviste au départ est ce
que vous le savez je pense que c'est le
général en accord bien sûr avec les
autorités du palais et il faut voir
alors je veux pas parler à la place et
du général bio farina et du dggn du
directeur de la gendarmerie nationale
mais je pense que il y à l'aspect
opérationnel le renforts opérationnels
que les réservistes peuvent apporter qui
est très important et il ya aussi un
côté attractivité puisque la gendarmerie
nationale est constamment en recherche
de réservistes dont
montrer que des réservistes peuvent être
intégrés au palais nationaux et
notamment à l'elysée
c'est une sorte de vitrine qui peut être
intéressante mais le premier aspect
c'est réellement l'aspect opérationnel
qui permet de renforcer les gendarmes
d'activ qui ont des emplois du temps qui
sont assez costaud et des caves
quelqu'un qui est malade qui absent où
il ya des permissions à prendre il faut
pouvoir occuper de façon optimum tous
les postes une dernière question
et lorsque vous effectuiez votre service
au titre de leur réserve pour palais de
l'elysée vous étiez donc vous aussi
comme les autres réservistes préposé à
une tâche de contrôle des entrées à
l'elysée à l'occasion de cette mission
vous n'étiez donc jamais en contact avec
le gspr et vous n'aviez pas non plus
d'autres activités au sein du palais
mon activité principale au sein du
palais c'est là le commandement de mai
réservistes c'est à dire vérifier qu'ils
sont bien valeur vérifier que la prise
en compte de leur armement se fasse dans
les conditions prévues par les textes de
vérifier j'allais constamment voir
sylvain j'avais j'étais pas toujours
derrière non plus pour les pour les
flics et entre guillemets mais je
vérifier auprès des gendarmes d'actifs
dégradés
si ces jeunes réservistes faisait bien
leurs services s'il était si c'était
police ils étaient courtois puisque
c'est ce qu'on leur demande
aux entrées donc je m'occupais
principalement de ceux là après
lorsqu'il y avait des événements type
dîner officiel
je me rappelle par exemple aussi du one
planet smit qui devait être en novembre
ou en décembre
je prêtaient main forte aux officiers
alors on peut le voir sur les images je
suis toujours en civil puisque les
officiers ou les cadres du sc eux nous
sommes en civil alors que les gens qui
sont dans les loges les gendarmes
d'actifs sont en tenue d'uniforme
moi j'étais en civil et je prêtais
concours je faisais le même travail que
mes camarades d'activ qui contrôlent les
entrées 1 contient des gros flux de
véhicules qui rentre on est là pour
vérifier avec tous les véhicules sont
bien les bons avec les bonnes plaques
d'immatriculation et que ce sont les
bonnes personnes qui rentrent au sein du
palais d'evreux je vous remercie celles
ci de madame marie madame marie mercier
vous aviez déjà posé une question mais
je vais vous redonner la parole merci
monsieur le président pouvez-vous nous
re préciser votre grade exacte et dans
l'es14 réservistes que vous aviez il y
avait-il des lieutenants colonels
vous pouvez répondre monsieur grâce je
suis chef d'escadron donc ce qui
correspond à commandant 4 4 barrettes
voilà et dans les réservistes que je
commandais il pouvait pas y avoir de
lieutenant-colonel puisqu'il aurait été
supérieur à moi il n'y avait de mémoire
que des brigadiers brigadier-chef
première classe ou même des ce qu'on
appelle des moquettes c'est à dire des
gens qui ont qui n'ont pas encore de
grade puisqu'il son tout frais issus
issue de leur formation
merci madame sophie chasse oui monsieur
crasse monsieur benalla a fait état de
de tensions avec l'administration de
l'elysée tout à l'heure dans la presse
aussi il y a quelques semaines
j'aurais voulu savoir si vous en aviez
connaissance à l'époque et à quoi vous
lui attribuiez monsieur christian en
moins jeune et je n'ai aucune
connaissance de tensions particulières
entre monsieur benalla et d'autres
personnes moi personnellement je n'ai eu
aucune friction aucune tension dans mon
service je pense que vous avez audi
auditionné le général bio-farina cas
puis vous vous dire qu'en globalité il
était satisfait de moi j'ai été notés
comme le sont les officiers va comme le
sont tous les gendarmes
tous les ans j'ai une notation plus que
satisfaisante pas fait état d' en ce qui
me concerne d'aucune frictions en ce qui
concerne monsieur benalla je sais pas je
peux pas vous répondre
mais à mon avis non ça se passait plutôt
bien voire très bien d'autres général
lors de son audition le colonel lavergne
ignorait son petit général devenu
général depuis qu'ils responsable
également de la sécurité du président de
la république nous a beaucoup étonné en
tout cas moi m'a beaucoup étonné
lorsqu'il a indiqué qu'il ne savait pas
s'il pouvait y avoir d'autres armes
déposées des tenues portées et qu'il n'y
avait même pas à le connaître par des
agents au sein de l'elysée
or bien sûr les gendarmes et les
policiers
une situation qui paraît tout de même un
peu étonnant est ce que vous êtes dans
la même situation
est ce que vous ignorez s'il existe
d'autres détenteurs d'un port d'armes
porteurs d'armes ou d'autres armes qui
peuvent être à l'elysée
autre que celle de ceux qui sont sous
vos ordres ou ceux qui sont sous les
ordres du gspr en général mais je
comprends la la réponse du général
lavergne parce qu'elle repose sur le
fait que si quelqu'un à titre privé à un
port d'armes
est ce que la présidence de la
république doit en avoir connaissance ça
c'est la question qu'il faut poser qui
peut être cela posera ton en tout cas
doit-on connaître de la détention d'un
port d'armes à titre privé des agents de
la présence de république
à l'heure actuelle non si vous faites du
tir sportif
vous avez l'opération de port d'armes et
si vous avez par extension une
autorisation de détention d'armes ou de
port d'armes
à l'heure actuelle nous n'avons pas
connaissance la question
l'autre question qui peut être et puis
sensible et qui découle de celle là c
est ce que les gens qui sont détenteurs
à titre privé d'un port d'armes
peuvent-ils utilisés dans le cadre des
missions qui leur seraient confiées au
sein de la présidence
la réponse est non évidemment et dans un
cas comme dans l'autre
mais dans le second cas il existe
évidemment un contrôle ne serait-ce que
visuel voilà c'est tout ce que je peux
vous répondre
alors mon général
la réponse parce que pour ce très très
précis a des idées
je rejoins ce qu'a dit le général
général d'un vernis oui mon général
bon prenons acte de votre réponse mais
c'est vrai que les citoyens nous
représentons les citoyens que nous
sommes peuvent être étonné que un
collaborateur de la présidence de la
république ayant un port d'armes titre
privé puisse apporter son arme à l'otan
samedi palais sans qu'il vous paraît ce
qu'il y ait là problème alors que vous
êtes en charge de la sécurité du palais
même si ce port d'armes est purement
privée je crois qu'il devrait y avoir
quand même des règles qui soient posés
pour que vous soyez informés de tout
port d'armes privé et de toute présence
d'une arme a mené par un collaborateur
quel qu'il soit à l'elysée je sors un
petit peu du cadre habituel de notre
audition où nous nous contentons nous
poser des questions mais c'est pour vous
dire la sensibilité de la question et
puis par ailleurs dans la question de
fond soit pile est je crois comprendre
qu'il y avait une autre dimension
j'ai essayé de la préciser saviez vous
que monsieur benalla avait un permis de
port d'armes et en quoi ce permis de
port d'armé et y était-il utiles à
l'exercice de sa fonction à l'elysée
peut-être que vous même la décrivez vous
revient sur la question
la question de savoir si légitime si on
doit être au courant de cet aspect de
port d'armes à titre privé mais le
besoin d'en connaître doit quand même à
minima reposer sur toujours la notion de
sécurité
je ne pense pas que à l'essence benalla
représenter une menace pour la
présidence de république telle que nous
la question et distingue parce que pour
monsieur benalla c'est pas un port
d'armes privé c'est important de
professionnels
donc il ya deux aspects dans la question
vient c'est pour ça qu'elle est un petit
peu complexe il ya effectivement celui
qui apporte dans le privé est ce que
c'est normal qu'ils puissent amener son
arme au palais sans que vous le sachiez
pour un motif de sécurité justement
et puis pour monsieur benalla et
d'éventuels autres collaborateurs du
président de la république qui aurait un
port d'armes à titre professionnel
est-ce que c'est justifié par leur
fonction et en particulier par celles de
monsieur ben la voilà les ces deux
questions en une très bien mais merci de
près de préciser c'est bien ça merci de
décortiquer la question parce que s'il
s'agit alors des collaborateurs de la
présidence qui ont un port d'armes titre
privé c'est dire qu'on sort du cadre de
l'action ghana qui lui un port d'armes
six professionnels donc cela ne peuvent
pas rentrer mais mais je pensais vous
faisait référence au port d'armes dans
les centres benalla qui lui un port
d'armes à titre professionnel
ah non non ce n'est pas globale excuse
moi mais les sénateurs soit on a un port
d'armes à titre professionnel
on est dans le cas de figure à aix-en
benalla auquel cas on a droit de porter
y compris dans l'enceinte du palais de
l'elysée soit on a un port d'armes à
titre privé et là vous ne rentrez pas à
l'elysée toute façon vous passez pas par
les détecteurs déjà et ensuite à partir
de là le système de contrôle se met en
branle et vous êtes refoulé y compris
pour un collaborateur qui arrivent en
voiture non
alors et et et enfin maintenant mais
cette première partie de la question et
en ayant obtenu une réponse
l'autre partie c'est effectivement est
ce que le port d'un professionnel de
monsieur benalla était justifiée par sa
fonction telle que vous nous l'avez vous
même décrite
je n'ai pas je n'ai pas assisté
num reporting de l'audition du chef de
cabinet c'est à lui à apprécier si
alexandre benalla d'abord et sky sont de
baignade à porter son arme dans le cadre
de ses missions à l'extérieur
personnellement moi je n'ai jamais vu
cette étude normes qui se voyait sous
une veste pardon
alors pardon madame donc de la conterie
pause rennes qui sont tout à l'heure
madame de la conterie possédons pas
rentrer donc personnellement vous n'avez
jamais dans les missions extérieures je
ne croyais jamais elles sont bien là bas
parce que c'était pas mon champ de
compétences et je ne les ai pas vus avec
une arme à l'extérieur et à l'intérieur
à l'intérieur il me semble effectivement
l'avoir vu avec une arme au retour d'une
séance de tirs je crois si ma mémoire
est bonne
et là il apporte et oui dans la
chefferie cabinet il y a le chef de
cabinet il ya le chef adjoint de cabinet
qui sont nommés au journal officiel
et il ya deux chargés de mission adjoint
au chef de cabinet dont faisait partie
monsieur benalla ses missions je vais je
vais les séquences et manière temporelle
et ça vous donner des éclairages sur
quels étaient ses missions et ses
relations avec le j'espère jusqu'au 1er
mai 2018 ces missions étaient triples la
plus importante mission c'était la
participation à l'organisation des
déplacements officiels du président de
la république sous l'autorité du chef de
cabinet à ce titre il assuré la
coordination des services qui concourt à
l'organisation du déplacement
conformément au programme qui sont
arrêtés par le chef de cabinet quand on
parle de coordination des services dans
ces services là il y a le j'espère mais
il n'y a pas seulement le j'espère il ya
tous les services qui concourent à la
sécurité et les autres services qui
concourent au déplacement parmi ceux qui
concourent à la sécurité
vous avez les services locaux bien
évidemment compétences avec les
profiteurs de prise sur l'opération
parisienne
ça va être les services de police ou de
gendarmerie
en département en province et les autres
services du palais c'est par exemple
service de l'intendance et services de
l'udinese est le service presse en fait
la chefferie cabinet c'est le chef
d'orchestre des déplacements du présent
d'un public monsieur benalla officier
toujours sous l'autorité du chef de
cabinet ça veut dire que par exemple
avec les autres services faisant en
sorte fectivement que le podium pour
président soit bien installé en lisant
un claudio visuel que le pupitre soit
bien là que les les élus soient bien
l'accueil et c'est que la presse soit
bien là quand il fallait que la presse
soit là voilà l'ensemble de ce que vous
avez connu ou connaissent et dans les
départements dans lesquels vous êtes à
ce titre étant le chef d'orchestre il
n'avait aucune autorité directe sur les
services de sécurité que ce soit sur le
gspm est entendue où que ce soit sur les
services compétents territoriale
territorialement qui sont sous
l'autorité du préfet de département ou
du préfet de police pour ce qui concerne
l'agglomération parisienne
ceci étant dit sa fonction de
coordination dans le cadre de l'ambition
des déplacements pouvait avoir des
conséquences en matière d'évolution du
dispositif
quand il y avait des corps non conforme
qui se présentait par exemple on avait
des élus qui étaient pas qui était pas
leur il fallait faire temporiser un
petit peu le séquençage quand y avait
des séquences qui est un peu raccourci
d'autres qui sont un petit peu qu'il
faut sauter parce que ça prend plus de
temps
les journalistes qui sont pas là où il
faut
ou alors on leur rajoute une petite
séquence on l'a tous a effectivement en
tant que chef d'orchestre et il donnait
les consignes sous l'autorité du chef de
cabinet et les tous les services qui
concourent au déplacement mais
s'articuler de manière à répondre à
cette orientation à ses orientations
les deuxièmes le deuxième volet de sa
mission de ses prérogatives
c'était l'organisation des déplacements
non-officiel du président de la
république
toujours sur le volet organisationnel
les visites de reconnaissance le contact
avec chaque interlocuteur que rencontrer
le président le lien avec le président
pour tous qu'ils étaient pour tous par
rapport à ces différents souhaits et là
aussi son rôle était un rôle de chef
d'orchestre
sachant que la partie sécurité incombe
en propre en matière d'exécutions aux
j'espère sous mon autorité
[Musique]
le troisième volet qui ne rendent pas
qui est pas en lien direct avec les
missions du j'espère c'était la gestion
des invitations pour le 14 juillet voilà
les trois volets de sa mission sous
l'autorité du chef de cabinet jusqu'au
1er mai 2018 et lieu les événements que
l'on connaît et la période de suspension
et au retour
à son retour au palais à compter du 22
mai 2018 il ya eu un recentrage de ses
missions dont qu'il avait toujours la
gestion des habitations du 14 juillet
est toujours l'organisation des
déplacements non-officiel du président
mais pour tout ce qui concerne les
déplacements officiels du président béni
participait plus est ces missions ont
été recentrés ont été recentrés par le
directeur de cabinet sur des missions au
sein du palais de l'elysée comme
l'organisation des réceptions
l'organisation de réunions importantes
etc etc
voilà un petit peu la description que je
peux faire des relations je veux dire
fonctionnelle entre monsieur benalla
sous l'autorité du chef de cabine et ça
j'y tiens beaucoup
est ce que monsieur b n'est là
contrairement à ce qu'on peut penser
était quelqu'un de contrôler et il
officiait sous l'autorité directe du
chef de cabine après au niveau des
relations
moi je n'ai j'ai toujours entretenu en
tant que chef de service
d'excellentes relations avec monsieur
bénard c'est quelqu'un qui était dévoué
disponible réactif opérationnel dans son
dans ces métiers dans son métier
organisation on entend qu'il entretenait
d'excellentes relations
également sur le plan humain et c'est le
cas aussi avec mes collaborateurs et mon
collaborateur ici présent en tant
qu'adjoint
donc le volet professionnel le volet
relationnel fonctionnel relationnel
après vous avez évoqué également là que
je cite sur la place publique monsieur
benalla faisait tahour et fait état de
relations tendues il alors moi il ne me
semble pas avoir entendu monsieur
benalla dire qu'il y avait des role of
qu'ils avaient des relations tendues
avec le avec avec le j'espère je pense
que c'est plutôt d'autres personnes qui
ont parlé de relations tendues avec le
j'espère de potentiel relations tendues
pour ce qui me concerne je n'ai jamais
vu monsieur benalla avec une arme dans
les dépassements du présent républicaine
ça c'est pour ce qui vous concerne pas
ce que vous avez des membres du groupe
de sécurité de la présidence de la
république qui ont eu à accompagner le
président de la république et en même
temps que le faisait monsieur benalla et
qui ont constaté qu'il portait une arme
je n'ai eu aucun retour en ce sens
merci mon colonel
est-ce que c'est madame jourdain
monsieur sur jourdain merci monsieur
président colonel nous essayons vous
l'avez compris de de consigne est de
confronter différentes informations qui
nous parviennent pour qu'elle ait un
sens bon ce qui n'est pas toujours le
cas notamment nous avons entendu mais
vous le savez les syndicats de police
qui faisaient état des relations
difficiles il avait utilisé un terme
beaucoup plus fort il avait utilisé pour
certains excécrable entre monsieur
benalla et les policiers avec lesquels
il travaillait et nous avons monsieur b
dallas lui même qui admet que les
relations étaient difficiles aussi à
dieu j'espère en parlant notamment de
friction ce sont des articles qui sont
parus auquel il a été fait allusion tout
à l'heure vous nous indiquez que vous
même et vos collaborateurs n'avaient pas
connu ce type de difficultés pour
relations étaient bonnes
alors quand vous parlez de vos
collaborateurs ont pas nouveaux
collaborateurs proches ou de
l'intégralité de vos hommes ce qu'ils
sont
sous votre commandement si tel est le
cas cet exercice l'intégralité des
sommes qui sont sous votre commandement
n'ont pas de difficulté avec monsieur
biya comment expliquez vous ces propos
tenus à la fois par lui et par les
syndicats
monsieur mon colonel pardon madame est
encore à porter je vais me permettre une
précision inc est une question avant de
vous répondre
[Musique]
par rapport à la mission de la mission
de la commission de votre commission qui
est qui et de devoir citer personne
n'ayant pas n'étant pas au sens pas
partie des fonds sécurité intérieure ont
pu ou peuvent participer à des missions
de protection ce qui est le rapport
entre les relations émissions des
personnes qui peuvent partir à des
missions de protection
si vous pouvez m'expliquer avant que je
puisse répondre s'il vous plaît alors il
s'avère que ce sont plutôt nous qui
posons les questions que les personnes
qui sont auditionnés pour autant de ce
que j'entendais de ce que vous avez dit
vous indiquer que monsieur benalla était
amené à donner des consignes dans son
rôle de coordination
on a pu le voir notamment dans une vidéo
qui a été récemment publiée par un
syndicat de police s'exprimer lors du
retour des bleus à l'égard de policiers
d'une façon assez raide
si je puis dire parce que ces consignes
n'ont pas pu être je dirais interprétées
comme des ordres à l'égard des membres
du j'espère qu'ils n'ont pas d'ordre à
recevoir du coordinateur
c'était ça le sens de ma question entre
tous je vous remercie madame c'est
beaucoup plus clair pour moi pour
pouvoir répondre
déjà je ne commenterai absolument pas
les propos tenus par les collègues du
syndicat de police c'est ça m'appartient
pas de les commenter
j'ai bien évidemment la visite
personnelle que je ne fournirai pas ici
mais je ne les commenterai pas et je ne
commenterai pas non plus les propos
tenus par monsieur b dallas puisque la
personnalité lui en leur revient puis je
suis passé dans sa tête
ceci étant dit le correspondant dans ce
que je décrivais tout à l'heure dans
l'émission le correspondant naturel du
chef de cabinet ou de ses adjoints c'est
le chef du j'espère donc à la limite si
quelqu'un avait eu à se plaindre de
parole un peu plus véhémente autant du
c'est moi ou mes adjoints moi à titre
personnel
super danois jamais
mal par les autres bien le contraire
après on imagine vous imaginez bien que
dans les déplacements des foyers moments
de tension on va pas forcément prendre
toutes les télés tous les
circonvolutions de courtoisie parce
qu'il faut que ça aille vite et que ça
et que ce soit très réactif
donc effectivement le chef de cabinet ou
sommet ou ses adjoints ne s'adresse pas
mais personnel directement parce que
c'est un rôle d'organisation donc le
chef d'orchestre le chef d'orchestre qui
s'occupe
il s'adresse aux par exemple aux chefs
des violons etc et et il s'adresse aux
chefs du j'espère et c'est celle du
j'espère qui traduit en termes
opérationnels les instructions du chef
de cabinet adjoint
bien évidemment si monsieur benalla où
le chef de cabinet ou le chef john
cabinet sarrau s'est dit avec personnel
ça ne paraîtrait quand même très étrange
ce qui n'est absolument pas le cas parce
que le seul à voir la vision globale de
la posture de sécurité adoptée c'est
celle du j'espère dans l'émission donc
le chef de cabinet ou monsieur bnl en
l'occurrence parce que vous en parle de
lui s'adresse aux chefs du j'espère ou à
ses adjoints
il ya voilà ce serait bien de faire ça
et on le met en musique sur le plan
opérationnel
mais moi j'ai pas j'ai pas j'ai pas eu
de retour particulier
indiquant une attitude particulière ou
vainement de monsieur benalla une
manière récurrente
d'ailleurs si je me souviens bien si je
me souviens bien là vous allez poser une
question aux syndicats de police en
demandant leurs sources a abandonné 6 et
donc c'est des sources locales
correspondants locaux du service de la
protection
il me semble que le chef du est ni le
chef du sds béni le directeur général de
la police nationale n'ont eu de retour
dans ce sens là ni moi-même bien
évidemment étant sous l'autorité
organique du chef du slp donc c'est donc
moi je suis très preneur d'avoir ce type
de retour là parce que peut-être que les
gens ont mal senties mais moi une
personne n'a fait le venu me le dire
très bien un preneur de je suis très
preneur si ici à des retours merci mon
colonel bien nous sommes nous aussi très
preneur d'information madame jourdain
merci monsieur le président colonel vous
nous avez indiqué tout à l'heure que
seul le j'espère été chargé de la
protection du président de la république
avant vous nous avons auditionné
monsieur le préfet de police des bouches
du rhône qui nous indiquait qu'à une
reprise d'un déplacement public du
président la république il avait vu
monsieur benalla en protection face à la
foule à l'instar des autres membres des
membres plutôt du j'espère alors je
souhaiterais savoir qu'à leur réflexion
ça vous inspire
et surtout si il n'est pas possible
c'est une hypothèse je n'en fais qu'une
hypothèse
lorsqu'il y a précisément des membres
des moments de tension comme vous
l'indiquez dans les manifestations que
monsieur benalla prennent de fait le
rôle d'un membre de la protection du
président de la république en colonel
madame dans les moments de
je fais attention au terme dans les
moments de tension c'est pas tensions
entre le j'espère monsieur benalla c'est
dans les moments de tension dans le cas
du déplacement dans les moments de
tension
j'irai le dispostif du j'espère reste au
à la main du j'espère le déficit de
sécurité restent à la main du chef du
j'espère
il est bien évident mais là on parle de
monsieur bédiala mais c'est le cas pour
le chef de cabinet pour le chef adjoint
de cabinet que lorsqu'on a des
mouvements de foule et qu' il ya
nécessité est bien le chef de cabinet ou
en l'occurrence monsieur b dallas ne va
pas s'effacer physiquement j'ai
participé ils vont donner un peu plus de
fluidité c'est évident quand vous avez
des gens qui se présentent devant pour
venir parler au président bayle vous
avez aussi un filtrage de la part du
chef de cabinet qui autorise ou pas le
fait de aux personnes du pouvoir accéder
au président donc oui ça peut donner
cette impression mais dans les faits
c'est absolument pas le cas merci de
votre réponse je précise je précise
quand même que c'est
je précise là on parle de monsieur
bénard mais c'est le code tous les
membres de la chefferie cabinet sac
abandonné en cas de nécessité mais
également ils vont peut-être un peu plus
poussée ça se voit par exemple sur
l'agriculture
on peut prendre d'autres images où
monsieur loge fait aussi 7 à cette
posture c'est normal c'est pas c'est pas
illogique mais ils font pas partie de la
bulle de sécurité dans le cadre de ses
déplacements du président de la
république je peux avoir des contacts
sur le terrain avec les services de
l'elysée comme la chaufferie du cabinet
le j'espère voir le commandement
militaire
or la question du 1er mai 2018
j'ai ainsi rencontré l'ancien adjoint au
chef de cabinet du président de la
république monsieur ben alla alexandre
une dizaine de fois dans le cadre de
dispositifs prévus par note de service
ces services n'ont pas soulever de
difficultés particulières
pour moi autorités civiles à la
direction de l'ordre public et de la
circulation
monsieur benalla était l'adjoint au chef
du cabinet du président de la république
il était en charge de l'organisation et
de la coordination des services sur les
déplacements du président sur plusieurs
aspects comme la sécurité générale où le
protocole en tant que chef adjoint de
cabinet monsieur ban a exprimé les
souhaits et les demandes de la
présidence de la république
je vous précise que je n'entretiens que
des relations professionnelles avec
monsieur ban à la je ne n'ai jamais vu
en dehors d'un dispositif de service
d'ordre prévu par note de service
je vous vois monsieur benalla je
l'appelle monsieur banal à ce dernier
m'appelle commissaire et me vouvoie je
n'ai pas le numéro de téléphone de
monsieur ben ali et je n'ai aucune
relation de copinage ou d'amitié avec
monsieur ban à la jeune entretien avec
lui que des relations strictement
professionnel dans le cadre de service
d'ordre prévu par une note de service
j'ai maintenant hâte à votre disposition
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs pour répondre à vos questions
je vous précise simplement comme vous
l'avez fait monsieur le président je
vous en remercie que je ne pourrais pas
répondre aux questions portant sur
l'effet du 18 et du 18 juillet faits
pour lesquels je suis mis en examen dans
cette affaire je vous dirais simplement
que dans cette affaire
j'estime n'avoir commis aucune faute de
nature pénale
et je me considère comme un
fonctionnaire de police loyal et honnête
et intègre
j'ai appris le 1er mai à 9 heures lors
de ma prise de service à l'île de la
cité
que monsieur benalla serait présent
comme observateur sur le dispositif de
manifestation revendicative du 1er mai
je les ai appris de la bouche du numéro
3 de l'année au pc c'est un contrôleur
général
pourquoi est-ce que je les a pris jallet
a pris puisque ce contrôleur général à
son bureau à côté du bien et qui se
trouve que le major de police qui était
le tuteur de monsieur ben alla le 1er
mai à son bureau en face donc aux cafés
comme quand vous venez au travail tous
les jours au café
ce contrôleur général lahmadi en
discutant également avec le major de
police qui étaient présents que monsieur
ben alla serait présent en tant
qu'observateur il n'y avait aucune
question problématique soulevée à ce
moment là puisque nous accueillons très
souvent des observateurs
moi même je suis souvent désigné comme
étant tuteur quand des organes y
commander observateurs viennent voir des
services d'ordre à la démo pc je les
fais sur les quatre derniers mois avec
un journaliste de m6 par exemple l'inde
enquête exclusive des mois je les fais
avec un membre du cabinet du préfet de
police
il se trouve que là le premier mais je
n'étais pas désigné je n'étais pas
désigné comme étant le tuteur de
monsieur bell puisque c'était le major
de police
j'ai eu cette information simplement
parce que nous partageons les presque
deux bureaux nos trois bureaux sur son
voisin
j'ai eu cette information dans ce
cadre-là par la suite sur cette question
de monsieur kraz moi je n'avais jamais
vu monsieur crasse dans le premier mais
je ne l'identifié pas et d'ailleurs j'ai
appris ça une sonde identité un monsieur
crade ainsi que son statut
de mémoire le le 19 juillet lors du
point presse de monsieur bruno roger
petit jeune a pris à ce moment là vous
avez terminé mais se creuse à lui je
crois va répondre aux questions alors
j'ai d'autres questions mais madame le
rapporteur souhaite imposer une aussi
oui merci monsieur le président une
question précisément sur le statut
d'observateur d'ordre général nous avons
beaucoup discuté sur l'équipement qui
fournit aux observateurs en tant que
tuteur est ce vous qui décidez de cet
équipement et pouvez vous nous dire en
quoi il consiste puisqu'en tant que
tuteur vous devez le constater
physiquement avant de répondre à votre
question à porter je vais également vous
préciser la procédure qui m'amène à être
désignée comme tuteur lors d'un hoax
alors ce qu'un observateur via vient
avoir un service d'ordre à la démo pc
la demande est faite au cabinet du
préfet de police le cabinet du préfet de
police rebascule la demande valider ou
non validée au des opc le des opc
rebascule cette demande au chef d'état
major qui est mon supérieur hiérarchique
direct et le chef d'état-major désigne
moi même ou un des 14 autres
commissaires de police de la direction
pour être le tuteur c'est comme ça que
ça se passe là des opc est une est une
maison extrêmement erard chizé nous
exerçons en tenue et la circulation de
l'information opérationnelle extrêmement
codifié une fois que j'ai entre
guillemets le sésame on me dit monsieur
creusa vous allez accueillir un
observateur à telle date pour telle
manifestation géant general également le
statut de cette soupe cet observateur et
ce qui peut voir on va dire que le
journaliste de m6 qui vient pour avoir
des images un petit peu on va dire
spectaculaire de l'ordre public pour un
reportage télé n'aura pas forcément le
même besoin les mêmes demandes en tant
qu'observateur que quelqu'un du
défenseur des droits
donc je prend également en compte cette
information-là et des instructions du
cabinet du préfet de police
accompagnant général le statut de
l'observateur ça c'est pour le
cheminement que ce soit ce soit bien
clair
je ne décide pas moi même d'être tuteur
est de prendre quelqu'un c'est pas du
tout comme ça que ça fonctionne sur la
deuxième question la question de
l'équipement
effectivement il est courant voire même
permanent en tout cas je le fais à
chaque fois quand j'ai un observateur
avec moi je lui donne un casque de
maintien de l'ordre
un casque de maintien de l'ordre pour
que ce dernier puisse se protéger
on a assez souvent moi j'exerce en tenue
dans tenue d'uniforme si vous voulez un
à la tête
en tant qu'autorité civil à la tête de
fonctionnaires des compagnies
républicaines de sécurité ou des
escadrons de gendarmes mobiles
j'ai ce qu'on appelle une combinaison
tactique et qu'un certain nombre de
protections
on prend assez souvent des projectiles
même sur des manifestations de 2 de
moyenne intensité s'appelle juste une
bouteille de bière je t'ai s'il voulait
donc il faut que l'observateur puisse
être protégé un casque première chose je
chante ici un ou les deux autres
questions qui vont être le brassard
police et l'acropole
puisque vous ne l'imposé pas mais je
vais vous répondre quand je suis tuteur
il ya encore une fois je n'étais pas
désigné de cutter le 1er mai je vous
parle d'eux comme moi je suis du terreau
d'un observateur de manière générale
cela ne me choque pas cela ne me choque
pas qu'un observateur et un poste
acropole pdg pour écouter la radio
pourquoi puisque c'est également liée à
sa sécurité
le message qu'on passe sur les ondes
radio et éminemment important on dit où
sont les forces en présences ou peuvent
être les perturbateurs ou peuvent être
les casseurs il faut que l'observateur
est également cette information là quand
je suis tuteur je veux pas passer la
moitié de mon service d'ordre a expliqué
à l'observateur ce qui se passe il peut
avoir une radio pour écouter en temps
réel et à voir ces informations là qui
sont des informations empirique qui sont
liées au maintien de l'ordre auxquelles
ils assistent qu'il ya une logique assez
à ce qu'ils aient tout le cheminement de
pensée jeunes et sur mes trois dernières
années à des opc jamais jamais
d'ailleurs c'est totalement impossible
je n'ai jamais vu un observateur parler
à la radio et je peux vous le dire vous
ne posez pas la question mais je peux
vous répondre
monsieur ban à la n'a pas parlé à la
radio le premier mais c'est impossible
le réseau radio delà des opc le réseau
radio 2 c est un réseau extrêmement
erard chizé ou peu de personnes parlent
pas avec une discipline ce qu'on appelle
une discipline sur les ondes qui est
extrêmement rigoureuse avec des ânes
idée indicatif radio traçable donc moi
je parle souvent à la radio à la dopc je
peux vous dire que les observateurs ne
parle jamais à la radio ou même si on
leur prête à un poste c'est uniquement
un poste pour écouter et que monsieur
banal a pas parlé à la radio le premier
effectivement cette affaire défraye la
chronique et qui plus est je dirais la
chronique dans les rangs des policiers
les policiers de terrain que nous
reposant temps à savoir les gardiens de
la paix pourquoi ce manifestement les
les agissements aujourd'hui en jeter une
une suspicion dans nos rangs et ont
provoqué aussi manifestement une rupture
de confiance avec la hiérarchie
policière rupture de confiance qui était
déjà palpable
malheureusement depuis trop longtemps
mais qui aujourd'hui s'accentue pourquoi
passionnés policiers de terrain ceux qui
sont soumis à des contraintes je dirais
effréné lié à la menace terroriste mais
pas qu'à la menace terroriste
aujourd'hui ne comprennent pas comment
se fait ce qu'il ait fallu je dirais
l'article et la vidéo publiée par le
monde pour qu'apparaissent les
agissements ô combien punissable et
condamnable de cet individu
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui la les gardiens
de la paix se pose des questions se
posent des questions sur ce qui a pu se
passer en amont se pose des questions
j'ai eu l'occasion de m'exprimer à
plusieurs reprises dans les médias
et aujourd'hui on parle on a
l'impression aujourd'hui d'être
confrontés une police parallèle dit et
par certains et je n'ai même employer un
mot très fort mais que dont j'assume la
complète responsabilité à savoir est ce
que nous étions confronté ni plus ni
moins qu'à des barbouzes
alors les policiers aujourd'hui sont en
attente de décision les policiers n'ont
pas très bien compris non plus je dirais
l'ailé les passages de témoins qui ont
eu effet entre les responsables de la
préfecture de police de paris entre
autres et aujourd'hui on a du mal à
comprendre nous gardiens de la paix on a
du mal à comprendre comment la haute
hiérarchie policière de la préfecture de
police n'était pas au courant des
agissements
de monsieur benalla et de quelques-uns
de ses comparses voilà en quelques mots
les je pense avoir suffisamment résumé
avoir été suffisamment concis pour
pouvoir vous donner l'état d'esprit
aujourd'hui des policiers que nous
représentons merci monsieur le président
ne sait ce que monsieur le secrétaire
général je vous prie de m'excuser de
cette intervention liminaire qui tout
sur croire avec des consignes je vais
demander à madame jourdain de bien
vouloir ouvrir le la séquence des
questions merci monsieur le président
merci messieurs de votre présence et je
vous assure nom de de la commission de
tout l'intérêt la considération que nous
portons à votre travail je voulais vous
demander si vous avez connaissance de ce
qu'est le statut d'observateur lorsque
quelqu'un vient sur une manifestation
notamment maintien de l'ordre comme ça a
été le cas et ce qui régit ce statut et
comment les choses sont censés se passer
pour la personne qu'ils observent quelle
tenue kalt a le droit de faire et l
accompagner
deux statues à ma connaissance il y en a
point aujourd'hui effectivement on a
quelques années tous les deux de prises
derrière nous et on a été confronté à la
présence d'observateurs donc de statut
absolument pas le statut c'est une
personne qui demande
il est fréquent que ce soit des
journalistes parfois même des magistrats
souvent liés d'ailleurs par la session
de formation de l'institut des hautes
études de la sécurité de la justice
l'équipementier leur doit être un
équipement de protection donc le cas
présent dans le cas du du 1er mai que
monsieur benalla ait eu un casque c'est
tout à fait légitime
pourquoi nous sommes dans un maintien de
l'ordre étaient réputés est difficile et
qu'il fut d'ailleurs particulièrement
violent on a tous et toutes en hymne
encore en mémoire les images de la fin
de manifestation à côté du pont
d'austerlitz mais c'est tout ce sont des
sols le seul équipement qui peut avoir
alors on peut accessoirement et ses jeux
les uv qu avoir parfois un observateur
qui puisse avoir un brassard police
pourquoi pas s'il faut également si on a
plusieurs je dirais unités
d'intervention au moment du maintien de
l'ordre
il faut qu'on puisse savoir si
réellement c'est un une personne
autorisée être en abords immédiats des
forces de l'ordre à part ça n'est rien
cette personne l'observateur bas se doit
par définition d'observer et en aucun
cas se doit de permettre d'intervenir à
quelques moments qu'il se soit sauf bien
évidemment comme le prétend jolie
monsieur bénard en fonction du code de
procédure pénale mais tel n'était pas le
cas ce jour là mes collègues aux crs
avaient une complète maîtrise de la
situation
merci monsieur le secrétaire général
monsieur le président en sueur messieurs
les ce et rohs je vais simplement vous
demandez quel écho vous avez des
relations de vos collègues avec monsieur
benalla je vais vous demander aussi
puisque théoriquement je dis bien
théoriquement il n'existe pas de chaîne
de commandement entre monsieur benalla
et les personnels de la police ou de la
gendarmerie nationales qui sont sous
l'autorité du ministère de l'intérieur
et t
de la hiérarchie de la police et de la
gendarmerie
et il arrivait que certaines certains de
vos collègues soit amené à s'opposer ou
à ne pas prendre en compte certaines
incitations pour parler de manière
modérée de monsieur benalla vous voyez
ce que je veux dire
et ne vous paraît-il ne vous
paraîtrait-il pas souhaitable qu'il eut
un statut clairement définis pour ce qui
est de la protection du président de la
république et des hautes personnalités
qui prévoirait que cela relève
exclusivement de la notorité des
personnes compétentes et formé de la
police et de la gendarmerie nationale
alors si concerne les relations de
monsieur benalla avec mes collègues du
groupe de sécurité du président la
république du gspr un tueur relève du
service de protection des hautes
personnalités
il ya une alternance en fonction du
président parfois ce sont nos collègues
gendarmes parfois ce sont les collègues
policiers qui assurent cette protection
depuis il a fin de semaine dernière les
langues commencent à se délier
manifestation met manifestement pardon
monsieur bénard a faisait régner la
terreur au sein du gspr monsieur benalla
n'hésitait pas d'après les propos qui
nous sont rapportées bien évidemment
nous n'étions pas témoin de ces propos
ni de ses agissements mais semblerait
manifestement que cette personne allait
jusqu à l insulte à l'encontre des
gradés et gardiens de la paix avant même
peut-être des officiers constituant ce
groupe
aujourd'hui il est bien évidemment pour
répondre à votre question il n'est pas
question aujourd'hui qu'un policier
puisse à avoir à obéir à une personne
qui ne relèvent pas de la hiérarchie
policière
c'est complètement inconcevable bien
évidemment il ya le le statut du corps
préfectoral
mais ça on est dans un autre domaine
parce qu'en l'occurrence jamais un
préfet ne se permet d'ordonner un
policier sauf en passant bien évidemment
par sa hiérarchie directe mais là on est
vraiment dans un système pour le moins
opaque d'une personne
qui a tenté notamment là encore les
langues se délient d'avoir une
intimidation constante et récurrente et
d'avoir tenté de réformer le système de
sécurité du gspr notamment pour le fort
de brégançon
ces dernières semaines mon organisation
syndicale n'a jamais été associé à ce
débat je sais qu'il a tenté de le faire
et pour le coup effectivement une
organisation syndicale autre que la
nôtre s'est opposé légitimement à cette
tentative je dirais de restructuration
mais là on était vraiment sur une
personne qui y jouait de sa relation
après le système pourrait-on dire
comment se fait-il que des policiers
puissent accepter d ordre d instruction
accepter autant peut-être de quolibets
sinon même d' insulte la problème la
problématique se fonde sur le fait que
nous sommes
inclus dans une chaîne et hiérarchique
aussi et que cette personne avait quand
même le statut de chef de cabinet
adjoint de l'élysée et faisait régner la
terreur à travers son statut tout
simplement vous savez quand un gardien
de la paix à un grade et un officier
voire même certainement un commissaire
en face de lui une personne disant j'ai
le une relation directe constante et
récurrente avec le président de la
république
peu d'entre nous sauf peut-être les
syndicalistes ce dont je suis convaincu
l heure au demeurant mais un
fonctionnaire de police et son club
péjoratif lambda ne s'opposera que très
rarement il allait il incarnait à
travers ses propos son attitude une je
dirais une posture de pouvoir suprême
il faisait part le fait régner la
terreur merci de cette réponse très
claire
donc mes chers collègues vous connaissez
la règle du jeu au maximum une petite
minute monsieur à la richard sur
secrétaire-général tout à l'heure dans
votre propos vous avez semblé associés
sous le nom de barbouzes à monsieur
benalla d'autres personnes sans établir
leur nombre vous sembliez site est ce
que vous appeliez des comparses
elle vous des éléments d'information qui
puisse nous être utile quant à une
pluralité de personnes ayant les mêmes
agissements
hors hiérarchie que monsieur benalla
entre autres nations et sénateurs nous
avons la personne qui a été je dirais
est prise sur par la vidéo secrétaire
général pour le jeu j'aurais dû vous le
préciser je suis désolé je vais demander
à chacun de mes collègues de poser des
questions notez-le et s'il vous plaît et
vous y répondre et d'un seul coup ce qui
nous permet d'être plus synthétique
c'est pour la bonne gestion de notre
audition et j'ai eu un moment de
distraction je vous prie de m'en excuser
monsieur collombat vous avez parlé de
police parallèle à la police mais comme
chacun sait normalement les blés
parallèle ne se rejoignent pas là
visiblement elles se rejoignent est
quelque part à la préfecture de police
et lorsqu'il a été interrogé par nos
collègues de l'udc de l'assemblée
nationale le préfet de police de paris a
parlé à ce propos de copinage malsain
est-ce que vous avez une idée de par
quel mécanisme
ce personnage a pu à a pu avoir cet
ascendant sur quand même des gens qui
sont pas nés de la dernière couvée enfin
a pu arriver à avoir autant de pouvoir
alors que c'était une usurpation pur
pure et simple est ce que et ça nous
donnerait peut-être sur la sur la voie 2
des ventes ul réforme ou clarification
des rôles de chacun pour justement
sortir de cette ambiguïté qu'inutile lui
a servi merci cher collègue madame
eustache brinio oui mais tout à l'heure
vous avez parlé de quelqu'un qui faisait
régner prenons la terreur avec un
certain nombre de fonctionnaires mais
moi je veux savoir depuis quand vous
connaissez l'existence de cette personne
au sein de l'elysée est ce qu'il est là
depuis longtemps est ce que il a été
intégré
aux côtés du président de la république
relativement tôt dans le cadre de ce
mandat parce que du coup aujourd'hui on
a l'air on comprend ce qui se passe avec
cette personne depuis tout à l'heure je
pense qu on a eu des des témoins des
extrêmes en éclairant je veux savoir
depuis quand vous vous connaissez
l'existence de ce personnage qui fait
régner la terreur à l'elysée merci merci
chers que les gays madame lherbier vous
avez parlé et messieurs de vous avez dit
que les crs maîtriser la situation
1 l'avocat de monsieur ban à l'ap a
parlé de débordements alors je voulais
savoir parce qu'ils disent et qu' ils
étaient venus en renfort et c'est un
petit peu seul que j'aimerais que vous
précisiez je remercie chers collègues
messieurs à la marque
j'aimerais pensez vous qu'il soit normal
que quelqu'un de 26 ans et même si la
valeur n'attend pas le nombre des années
soit éventuellement chargé de
réorganiser le jus espère et comment
l'expliquez vous merci chers collègues
enfin madame marie mercier
merci monsieur le président messieurs
vous sembler quelque peu excédé par
cette histoire
j'aimerais savoir si dans votre carrière
vous avez déjà eu à faire un
comportement de ce genre je remercie
chers collègues
et enfin dernière question celle de
madame marie b ça rejoint un peu ce qui
a été dit il ya quelque chose qui
m'intrigue dans ce que vous dites vous
insistez énormément sur les
comportements déviants mais en même
temps derrière il ya un système qui
permet de ceux de terre ces
comportements déviants
donc j'aimerais que vous nous aidiez à y
voir plus clair sur cette différence
très bien alors monsieur le secrétaire
général et monsieur le secrétaire
général délégué à vous de jouer
pour répondre à toutes ces questions
dont certaines signées brésil en direct
quand je reprendrai effectivement la
première est la question monsieur le
sénateur chat sur les d'autres comparses
ont hormis gelé dit tout à l'heure
hormis celui qui a été vu employés de la
république en marche un d'après ce qu'on
peut savoir
selon les éléments en ma possession il
semblerait manifestement qu'au sein du
gsp un jean sisto bien sûr
semblerait avec le conditionnel qui
s'imposent qu'effectivement au sein du
j'espère nous avions un groupe un groupe
de deux personnels hors police et or
jean namory dans hors du champ de la
mission régalienne de sécurité qui doit
être celle du gsp à la protection du
président avec lui et de son épouse qui
en l'occurrence était d'aider des civils
les privés et c'est bien pour ça que
j'ai employé depuis le début depuis
jeudi dernier jean pas le terme de
barbouzes parce que ces gens là n'ont
aucune habilitation
ce ne sont ni plus ni moins que sans que
ce soit péjoratif j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour les métiers de la sécurité
privée
mais ce sont des vigiles qui était
employé aujourd'hui manifestement par
monsieur benalla dans le cadre de la
protection de la présidence de la
république
oui effectivement monsieur le secrétaire
général cette information que vous nous
donnez est extrêmement importante est ce
que vous êtes en mesure de la source et
achever la source et moi j'ai les
renseignements que j'ai c'est bien
évidemment à travers nos réseaux de
délégués au sein du service de
protection des hautes personnalités sphp
et bien évidemment par part est fait je
dirais sur le gspr les éléments que j'ai
eus m'ont été rapportés effectivement
par mes représentants locaux qui m'ont
dit effectivement qui m'ont affirmé
qu'ils avaient des groupes de 2,2 privé
qu'il travaillait en l'occurrence avec
monsieur benalla et qui est provoqué
justement détention avéré entre eux les
fonctionnaires de police et monsieur
benalla et ses comparses qui en
l'occurrence et ça serait d'ailleurs un
des motifs de la réorganisation du gspr
dans la perspective de la protection du
fort de brégançon pendant les vacances
du président monsieur le secrétaire
général est ce que vos correspondants
vous vous ont indiqué le nombre de
vigiles que non je n'ai pas je n'ai pas
nombre précis monsieur le président mais
on peut s'en enquérir et je ne manquerai
pas de porter à votre connaissance si
vous me le permettez de tels
renseignements et je ne vous le permet
pas je vous le demande bien reçu
monsieur le président j'ai voulu
nécessaires à la collecte du
renseignement peut entamer sans délai je
vous remercie et vous avez peut-être
d'autres 6 eu à nous apporter non pas ce
port ce domaine on voit la madame
j'entends madame eustache brinio et je
pose à sa place la question depuis quand
le savez vous éprouvez vous pourrez vous
nous l'indiqué aussi je pourrais je
pourrais je pourrais vous l'indiquez
effectivement les langues se délient
parce que vous comprenez aisément que
quand on essayait d'avoir des
renseignements le week-end dernier il y
avait je dirais une chape de plomb est
quelque peu d'aidé refus de répondre à
nos sollicitations en la matière ce qui
se comprend aisément depuis les
fonctionnaires qui sont affectés aux
j'espère qu'ils ont un devoir de réserve
en l'état seuls les représentants du
personnel pourront s'enquérir de la
chose et on essaiera d'avoir le maximum
de renseignements pour que l'on puisse
apporter des éléments nécessaires à
l'enquêté
messieurs chauvette vous voulez apporter
des précisions je voulais simplement
apporter une précision mais qui est qui
doit être évidente à mon sens pour tout
le monde sait que compte tenu de la
sensibilité de cette affaire et de
l'endroit où était affecté entre
guillemets monsieur benalla c'est à dire
ni plus ni moins dans la proximité du
président de la république il arborait
systématiquement sa carte
à n'importe quel fonctionnaire qui est
rencontraient du cabinet donc de
l'elysée il est bien évident que faire
parler nos collègues et je répond
directement à la question précédemment
que ce soit les gars des gradés et
gardiens de la paix mais aussi que la
moyenne est rare chez les officiers et
les commissaires personne n'allait se
répandre sur des travers qui auraient pu
été effectués et semble-t-il puisque
secrétaire général vient d'annoncer qu
effectivement les langues se délient on
apprend qu'il ya eu plusieurs quoi
qu'ils n'étaient pas de même niveau
certes mais qui à la fois faisait état
d' altercation avec les forces de police
et de gendarmerie sur certains le
maintien de l'ordre où il souhaitait
prendre la tête du dispositif ou
détourné l'action de la police nationale
sur certaines interventions et qui plus
est pour ceux qui éventuellement pouvait
trouver ça totalement anormal et
éventuellement le faire savoir
et bien il y avait effectivement cette
carte qu'il présentait qu'il arborait
que là pour le coup c'était plus
difficile à faire savoir où les gars au
déroulement carrière que vous pouvez
bien comprendre c'est chouette c'est
très important ce que veut dire je vous
en remercie mais cela appelle de ma part
une question complémentaire quelques
couacs pouvez vous les décrire alors
effectivement il a été porté à notre
connaissance mais on pourra amener des
précisions encore plus clair d après
c'est que assez régulièrement la
présence de monsieur benalla sur des
manifestations où il était forcément
autorisés à y aller sur ces
manifestations et bien systématiquement
il il essayait de prendre la main sur le
dispositif y compris auprès des hauts
gradés et certains de nos collègues
nombre de nos représentants au plus
confirmé qu'il y avait eu des tensions
et où il a été écarté par le fait qu' il
souhaitait intervenir ou décider de tel
ou tel
manipulation des effectifs donc vous
voulez dire que l'autorité de police
s'est refusée à ce moment-là à déférer à
ses ordres à ses instructions à ses
recommandations wii ou à sa volonté d
agir autrement
très bien je vous remercie madame
benbassa brune ultime question nous
avons juste le temps et merci monsieur
le président une toute petite question
pourquoi pourquoi cette sécurité privée
qui prend la place de la police aux
halles elysées mais quel est l'objectif
pourquoi cette sécurité privées ces
personnes que vous appelez des barbouzes
à côté de la police qui l'emplît seo
j'espère à sa fonction de sécurité du
président merci je préside je reprends
je reprends dessus de la réponse à la
question madame vous savez madame la
sénatrice jeu très franchement je crois
que c'est aux prisons la pluie qui vous
poser la question en la matière sinon
monsieur ab à monsieur benalla pourquoi
ou sans doute à monsieur le directeur de
cabinet de l'elysée nous pour ça on ne
rompt ne sait pas on apprend ces choses
au petit au fur et à mesure voilà talent
une question m'a été posée depuis quand
je connais monsieur benalla très
simplement j'ai été reçu par président
de la république à la fin du mois de
janvier dans le cadre des changes bien
évidemment dans le cadre du dialogue
social qui s'imposaient prison n'avait
plus il voulait s'enquérir de l'état des
des forces de sécurité de notre
république doit bel république et j'ai
croisés dans un établissement public
chez croisé cette personne sans savoir
qui c'était c'est quand j'ai vu ces
photos à paraître dans tous les médias
de france ils ont même du monde entier
mercredi et jeudi que je me suis
remémoré avoir vu cette personne qui
n'avait de cesse déjà les potes de
parler de 2 de son étui pour son arme et
pour moi et mon collègue qui étaient
présents ce jour là pour nous il
s'agissait d'un collègue policier du
gspr ils avaient tous les latitudes et
preuve en est faite
ils avaient tous les attributs et je
vous fais grâce de la voiture c'était en
journée c'était un lundi matin de très
bonne heure dans un bar pas très éloigné
à mi chemin entre entre beauvau et
l'elysée madame
voyez vous voyez alors s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît il faut qu alors qu'il y
ait ici aussi une certaine police de
notre commission et le rôle ingrat que
j'accepte d'assumer ses de l'exercer
mais je le fais à titre officiel
alors monsieur le secrétaire gilles
boulet ajouter quelque chose mais moi je
vais vous rappeler aussi qu'il nous
qu'il vous faut répondre à la question
de madame marie mme mercier
tout à l'heure à laquelle vous n'avez
pas répondu qui vous a demandé si dans
votre expérience de policiers vous avez
déjà rencontré ce type d' usurpation
d'autorité venant d'un collaborateur de
la présidence de la république voilà
alors je vous laisse reprendre la parole
n'ont jamais non jamais j'ai 36 ans de
police nationale derrière moi j'ai
beaucoup de maintien de l'ordre
je n'ai jamais été confronté à ce genre
d'agissements jamais jamais au grand
jamais dieu jamais il ya aussi une
question monsieur le président si on
devait arrêter sur le sur le l'âge 26
ans 26 ans 26 ans vous savez unité sgp
police force ouvrière n'a de cesse de
lutter syndicalement parlant pour
permettre à nos collègues d'obtenir le
grade supérieur légitimes attentes
légitimes attentes
aujourd'hui pour accéder au grade de
brigadier-chef qui on en est brigadier
sur moyenne 15 à 20 ans et il faut
surtout pas être bancaire de police dans
la creuse dans les landes
au pays basque où dans le morbihan parce
que là ça sera 35 ou 40 ans sinon même
dans les antilles d'envoyer c'est pour
nous c'est proprement parler scandaleux
comment cet individu a 26 ans et plus
est nommé lieutenant colonel en
l'occurrence assis véritablement une
insulte à nos camarades d'armes que sont
nos collègues gendarmes
donc c'est une insulte effectivement on
peut faire valoir le côté expertise mais
passez moi du peu l' expertise en la
matière est complètement irrecevable sur
la la question enfin je dirais la la
mise en avant par les avocats de
monsieur benalla du fait que nos
collègues crs étaient débordés le
premier mais je suis intervenu à
plusieurs reprises dans les médias en
disant que le premier mais même si ça a
peut-être tarder un peu l'intervention
devant le mcdonald's et devant la
concession auto à hauteur du pont
d'austerlitz
j'ai considéré à l'époque que les
effectifs étaient largement dimensionnés
on est dépendant sous-dimensionnement on
était largement bien dimensionné et
qu'en l'occurrence dans un tel cas il
valait mieux attendre
malheureusement valait mieux je dirais
constaté des dégâts matériels que
d'avoir concédé des dégâts humains donc
en aucun cas les crs n'ont été en
position d'être débordés même sur cette
place le 1er mai absolument pas je ne
complète maîtrise de la situation
les crs se sont des professionnels
reconnus dans le monde entier en matière
de gestion du maintien de l'ordre au
même titre d'ailleurs que gendarmes
mobiles pour lui il faut associer nos
collègues gendarmes en la matière lors
il n'y a jamais été question de
débordement le fait de devoir à tout
prix saisir au vu d'un article du code
de procédure pénale faire saisir ces
c'est une infraction
franchement franchement c'est fait à
l'eau de rose cet argumentaire passez
moi l'expression
je connais monsieur benalla pour l'avoir
croisé depuis la prise de fonction le 28
août dernier lors de déplacements ou de
cérémonies auxquelles participait le
président de la république et auquel
j'étais convié jeu l'identifier
clairement comme un collaborateur du
chef de cabinet de la présidence de la
république dont l'une des missions
centrale habituelle d'un cabinet est
d'organiser ses déplacements ou ces
cérémonies officielles
il était donc tout à fait naturel qu'ils
soient présents dans ces circonstances
une dizaine de fois pour ce qui me
concerne la dernière dans la tribune
officielle du 14 juillet au cours de
kate desquels je n'ai jamais remarqué de
sa part une attitude déplacée ou qu'ils
me soient apparus intrusive
je n'ai jamais eu à échanger avec lui
d'autres propos que de courtoise
salutations je n'ai pas le souvenir
d'avoir participé à des réunions travail
en sa présence
il faut dire que mes contacts avec la
présidence de la république sont rares
ces relations étant normalement réservé
au cabinet du ministre qui au besoin me
sollicite lorsque des commandes
techniques sont exprimées par la
présidence en ce qui concerne plus
particulièrement les événements de la
place de la contrescarpe du 1er mai il
m'apparaît important de vous décrire
rapidement l'organisation des opérations
de maintien de l'ordre en france sur
l'ensemble du territoire national
à paris comme ailleurs le préfet
territorialement compétent à la pleine
responsabilité de la gestion de l'eau
re public c'est sous son autorité que
sont organisées les dispositifs
opérationnels qui seront mis en oeuvre
sur le terrain par les forces de police
ou de gendarmerie parfois combinées
mon rôle consiste mon rôle de directeur
général de la police nationale consiste
donc à fournir aux préfets préfets de
police compris les forces mobiles
nécessaires au service d'ordre qu'il
prévoit selon les renseignements dont je
dispose sur le contexte de l'événement à
gérer et en fonction des forces
disponibles qu'elles appartiennent à la
police les crs ou à la gendarmerie
nationale des escadrons de gendarmerie
mobile pour le 1er mai ce sont 15 forces
mobiles de la réserve nationale dix crs
et cinq escadrons de gendarmerie mobile
que j'ai mis à disposition du préfet de
police
s'ajoutant aux huit crs qui constitue l'
enveloppe parisienne permanente dont il
dispose soit un total de 23 unités
s'ajoutant elle même aux forces
territoriale de la préfecture au terme
des opérations
les services de police transmettent à
mon état major un compte rendu
synthétique décrivant leur dérouler le
bilan blessure interpellation dégâts
éventuels incidents
s'agissant du 1er mai le télégramme de
la crs numéro 15
présente sur la place de la contrescarpe
qui est une crs basée à béthune rapporte
les événements graves auxquels ces
fonctionnaires ont été confrontés
pendant toute la durée de leur vacation
commencé à 12h40 et terminer à 23 heures
sans mentionner de faits impliquant des
observateurs
rétrospectivement une ligne de ce
télégramme de compte rendu fait sans
doute référence aux événements qui
motive la formation de des commissions
d'enquêté parlementaires en cours
elle est ainsi libellé 20h15
deux individus interpellés violence
contre agent de la force publique remis
à la brigade d'information de voie
publique
au-delà de cette information
opérationnel transmises par les services
de police eux mêmes à mon état major je
peux être rendue également destinataire
par les préfets ou par les directions
centrales placé sous mon autorité
d'informations sur le comportement
inadapté voire fautif du
l'idée d'un ou de plusieurs
fonctionnaires sur la base d'éléments
circonstancié et vérifier je déclenche
alors une procédure disciplinaire en
saisissant en saisissant par dont
l'inspection générale de la police
nationale avec mesure de suspension le
cas échéant et cela indépendamment des
poursuites judiciaires éventuelles
décidée par le parquet compétent
au terme des événements du 1er mai aucun
signalement de ce type n'a été porté à
ma connaissance aucun incident dans la
conduite des opérations ne m'a été
révélé
je n'ai été informé des agissements
répréhensibles de monsieur benalla qu'à
l'occasion de la publication du journal
le monde daté du 18 juillet al'inverse
le 19 juillet les agissements résumé
délictuelle de trois fonctionnaires de
la démo pc qui ont participé à
l'extraction des images de vidéo
protection publique et à leur
communication à monsieur benalla monte
été signalée immédiatement compte tenu
de la gravité des faits avec la
circonstance particulière qu'ils avaient
été commis par des cadres des hauts
cadres de la police nationale qui ne
pouvait ignorer qu'ils commettaient
sciemment une infraction
j'ai donc donné instruction à mes
services avant même la décision
d'autorité judiciaire de prendre sans
délai les actes de suspension j'ai
également demandé au préfet de police de
saisir l'igpn à des fins décide
disciplinaire ce qu'il a fait il me
reviendra in fine et car c'est ma seule
compétence de prendre les sanctions qui
s'imposent rang au terme des procédures
disciplinaires qui vont se dérouler les
sanctions sont en général signée par mon
délégataire le directeur des ressources
et des compétences de la police
nationale à l'exception des révocations
dont je me réserve l'exclusivité des
signatures compte tenu de la gravité de
la mesure pour être complet et j'en
finirai par là je précise que l'igpn
avait été rendu destinataire vous
entendrez je crois me l'a mené j'ai tout
à l'heure pour être complet je précise
donc que l'igpn avait été rendu
destinataire sur sa plate forme de
signalement en ligne d'image de la scène
de la contrescarpe ces images avaient
été postées le 3 mai à 2h13 par un
internaute sous pseudo ne permettant pas
d'identifier
ne se présentant pas comme protagonistes
de la scène filmée mais indiquant
simplement l'avoir trouvée sur les
réseaux sociaux
l'inspection générale dans les
circonstances particulières de ce
signalement en l'absence d'autres
plaintes et dans le contexte des grandes
violences subies par les forces de
l'ordre lors de ces manifestations du
prêt du 1er mai n'a pas considéré
pertinent de déclencher des
investigations je dois préciser que les
images postées était prise sous un angle
qui ne mettait pas en évidence des
violences avérées l'igpn a considéré
légitime au vu de ces images lusage de
la force appliquée
l'inspection ne disposait alors que de
ses seules images et non celle qui
depuis ont été diffusées largement prise
sous différents angles par différents
opérateurs qui sont aujourd'hui à notre
disposition mais dont ne disposaient pas
l'igpn dans cette fameuse nuit du 3 mai
à 2h13 ces images celles qui ont été
déposés sur la plateforme en ligne ont
toutefois été conservé au cas où une
plainte serait ultérieurement déposer ou
un signalement exploitables post t on
sait aujourd'hui que ça n'a pas été le
cas
l'igpn ne m'a pas tenu informé de ce
signalement ce que l'on considère
parfaitement normal dans l'état de
connaissance des faits qui était le sien
à ce moment là la chef de l'inspection
madame monéger que je rencontre très
régulièrement ne manque jamais de me
rendre compte des faits graves qui sont
portés à sa connaissance et des des hits
des diligences qu'elle entreprend en
toute indépendance et je dois le
souligner sans aucune faiblesse
mais la gravité de la scène que j'évoque
ne sera établi que bien plus tard
lorsque l'illégitimité des
interpellateurs entre guillemets sera
révélé à l'igpn comme à moi même par
l'article du monde
éclairant le sujet d'un jour tout à fait
nouveau et caractérisant des infractions
que l'autorité judiciaire vient de
qualifiés pénalement
je me tiens monsieur le président madame
monsieur les co-rapporteurs à votre
disposition mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs pour répondre à vos questions
et vous apporter toutes précisions
utiles à vos travaux
jce de l'accueil des observateurs de la
sphère benalla dans le respect des
investigations judiciaires en cours et
dans les limites de ce que j'en connais
ou plus généralement de l'organisation
de mes services en matière de protection
des hautes personnalités
merci beaucoup monsieur directeur
général monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
directeur général nous avons je crois a
écouté avec beaucoup d'attention
votre propos liminaire qui me conduit à
vous poser les questions suivantes
première question est ce que vous étiez
au courant du fait que qu'avait été
sollicité pour monsieur banal a le
statut d'observateur pour les
manifestations du 1er mai vous nous
dites que dans le compte rendu qui vous
ait été fait que personne ne vous a
informé du fait que il y a eu des actes
de violence commis en présence de
nombreux policiers par deux personnes
n'appartenant pas à la police nationale
ayant donc un statut d'observateur
comment est il possible que cela n'est
jamais remonté ne soit jamais remonté ce
jour là quelles conséquences en
avez-vous tiré
d'autre part il est établi que dès le 2
mai aussi bien le ministre de
l'intérieur que le directeur de cabinet
du président de la république était en
possession des vidéos démontrant
l'implication de monsieur benalla le
préfet de police également eu pouvez
vous dans ces conditions et 10 revers
confirmé que vous n'avez eu aucune
connaissance de ces documents en votre
qualité de directeur général de la
police nationale
et d'autre part vous avez été je suppose
informé du fait que monsieur benalla
étaient déchargés pendant les mises à
pied pendant deux semaines de ses
fonctions vous n'avez pas pu quand même
l'ignoré
je suppose que vous vous êtes interrogé
si vous n'avez pas eu connaissance des
vidéos sur les raisons pour lesquelles
ils étaient mises à pied et vous avez
entendu comme nous mêmes le porte parole
de l'elysée disant que eux une fois que
ces quinze jours de mise à pied seraient
terminés l'intéressé serait démis je
cite de toutes fonctions de sécurité et
de protection
dans ces conditions vous n'avez pas
manqué d'observer que jusqu'au 14
juillet inclus ils continuent à exercer
ces missions qu'elle a été à cet égard
votre réaction
et de manière plus générale et j'en
termine nous avons hier reçu les
représentants des personnels de la
police nationale que vous connaissez
parfaitement qu'ils nous ont fait part
de grandes difficultés dans les
relations avec monsieur benalla que
quelle est votre appréciation votre
jugement sur les interférences entre ces
actions et les actions menées
légitimement par les représentants de la
police nationale et enfin s'il a
participé à des réunions de commandement
relevant de la police nationale vous
avez dit que vous n'avez jamais
plus observé cela avez vous été informé
où avez vous même été appelé à prendre
des décisions notamment pour la réunion
de commandement qui se déroulait à la
suite des faits du 1er mai à la
préfecture de police de bari vole à des
questions extrêmement précise
je me limiterai là monsieur le président
mais je pense que vos réponses précises
éclaireront la commission monsieur le
directeur général m saviez-vous si il y
avait un opérateur autorisé le 1er mai à
paris là
sur la place de la contrescarpe ou
ailleurs la réponse est non
même s'agissant de l'intéressé de
quelqu'un de l'elysée oui la réponse est
non je n'ai pas le savoir
je n'ai pas naturellement elle savoir je
ne suis pas l'autorité qui délivre ce
type de toute autorisation le préfet de
police et istres humaine devant
l'assemblée nationale
clairement en disant qu'il était
extrêmement jaloux d'ailleurs de géo
comprend 2 2 de son pouvoir de décision
en ce domaine
il n'a pas à me rendre compte il
accueille tous les observateurs qui
souhaite et je n'ai pas à savoir qui est
ou pas observateur quel que soit
d'ailleurs la qualité de cet observateur
donc non je ne le savais pas et j'ajoute
je n'avais pas à le savoir vous vous
indiquer que les vidéos présentent d d d
d actes de violence
commis par par des personnes qui
n'appartiennent pas au service mais
encore une fois et aussi surprenant que
ça puisse jouer que ça puisse vous
paraître lorsque l'igpn regarde les
images pris sous un angle particulier
d'ailleurs qui sont déposés sur sa
plateforme
elle ne n'identifie pas des pros tegan
it des protagonistes qui ne serait pas
policier elle voit des gens casqué qui
interviennent en civil ce qui est une
pratique habituelle ou côté des inuits
est constituée d'ordre public
il y à des opérateurs en civil qui sont
chargés des interpellations et donc à ce
moment là dans cette danseuse visionnage
que filiger peine il n'y a aucune raison
de penser que ce sont il ya là des
protagonistes que qui ne sont pas des
policiers
vous m'interrogez sur le fait que le 2
mai il est mis en lumière le fait que
monsieur benalla se trouvaient là et
vous vous étonnez que je ne sois pas au
courant que je ne soit finalement au
courant de cette affaire comme mon
collègue gérald l'usure et d'ailleurs
qui vous l'a dit à l'instant qu'à la
lecture du journal le monde je vous
confirme que entre le 2 mai et la
parution de l'article du genre de monde
je n'étais pas je n'ai pas été mis au
courant de ces circonstances très
particulières vous m'a dit quand je suis
sous serment madame je la firme et je
vous le dis de manière extrêmement
affirmative et je le confirme haut et
fort je n'ai jamais été mis au courant
de la participation de monsieur benalla
de monsieur kraz dont j'ignore tout ce
jour là
et vous dire je suis très conscient que
dépose sous serre bien entendu j'ai
préféré vous n'avez pas à répondre aux
interpellations quand je n'ai pas donné
la parole à mes collègues non mais cette
interpellation semble mettre en cause
oui oui la santé de mes propos et
permettez moi de réagir assez ferme
c'est la raison pour laquelle je prenais
la parole pour commenter cet incident
monsieur le préfet oui je vous laisse
terminer votre réponse les questions de
monsieur soeurs étaient nombreuses sur
la mise à pied de monsieur benalla j'en
ignore tout mais là aussi rien
d'étonnant monsieur benalla n'est pas un
de mes employés je n'ai pas de pouvoir
décisionnaire sur lui j'ai beau
directeur général de la police nationale
je n'ai pas un fichier que je consulte
tous les jours sur tous les
collaborateurs d
comment dire des plus hautes autorités
de l'état et donc monsieur je ne veux ni
j'ignore tout et c'est absolument normal
des relations de professionnels de
monsieur benalla avait sa hiérarchie et
je prends connaissance de la lettre de
mise à pied que signe monsieur strzoda
dans le journal le monde
vous me parlez ensuite des syndicats qui
de ce que je comprends commence à dire
qu'il y avait des relations compliquées
entre monsieur benalla des
fonctionnaires exécrable je je je je
alors deux choses j'ai regardé vos
auditions d'hier en tout cas
partiellement et monsieur le président
bah avait repris un moment donné les
choses en disant les syndicats disent
que les langues commencent à se délier
donc ses relations exécrables videmment
finalement de ce que je comprends elles
sont mises à jour de manière extrêmement
récente
moi je n'ai jamais encore une fois était
destinataire d'information accréditant
cette ambiance exécrable
je ne dis pas qu'elles n'existent pas je
n'en sais rien personne
dans mon entourage dans mes
collaborateurs m'ont rapporté cela ait
aucun syndicat tous les secrétaires
généraux des syndicats de la police
nationale ont mon numéro de portable
personnel
ils ne se privent pas d'utiliser à aucun
moment les syndicats qui ont un accès
direct à ma personne ne m'ont alerté sur
ce sujet donc je prends acte que les
langues se délient et qui semble qu'il y
ait eu
reste à aller confirmer mais encore une
fois je n'ai pas de je n'ai pas de
d'information là dessus en dehors de
celles qui sont révélés à votre
commission et puis les réunions de
commandement moi je ne je ne participe à
aucune réunion de commandement du j
espere ou de la sécurité d'élise et sané
ça n'est pas mon rôle pas plus que c'est
le rôle de du général il jurait pourtant
c'est une idée composer et de policiers
et gendarmes
elles sont placées sous l'autorité d'un
chef d'unité ans
actuellement c'est un cetain c'est un
gendarme est jeune et de près ou de loin
à la je n'ai pas de près ou de loin
participé à des réunions de commandement
je serais bien incapable de vous dire si
monsieur comment dire benalla et
participe est il était en situation ou
s'ils s'imposaient comme comme donneurs
d'ordre ce qui serait gênant si ce
quelqu'un mais je n'en sais rien
monsieur de directeur général nous
sommes intéressés naturellement par
votre témoignage sur les faits et je
vous remercie des précisions que vous
nous apportez mais nous sommes aussi
intéressés par votre expertise comme
directeur général de la police nationale
les par votre expérience de l'état
nous sommes nous avons besoin
d'interpréter ce qui s'est passé de le
comprendre il ya pour nous en tenant
pour acquis tout ce que vous nous avez
dit une discordance entre la précision
de la formation que le ministre de
l'intérieur son cabinet le préfet de
police le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république détiennent
des de demain et l'information mise à la
disposition de votre propre direction
générale et de l'inspection générale de
la police nationale et nous sommes en
droit mais enfin peut-être serons-nous
démenti de faire l'hypothèse que les
autorités que j'ai cités ont ensemble
convenu de ne pas aller plus loin que ce
qui a été fait et alors que les faits
nous paraissait d'une grande gravité de
tenter de ne pas saisir la justice de
ces faits ni saisir l'inspection
générale de la police nationale est ce
que cette interprétation ou paraît
plausible vraisemblable crédible compte
tenu de votre expérience
le
je confirme encore une fois d'avoir été
informé de la présence de monsieur
benalla sur les événements du 1er mai
qu'à la lecture du journal le monde et
je n'étais pas dans la boucle
apparemment restreinte de ceux qui
savaient l'igpn va davantage après vous
suggérer une autre question la saisine
de la justice la gravité des faits la
saisine de la wii mais je ne savais pas
pour vous en faire reproche
comprenez moi bien je mets passé vous
vous interrogez sur des faits mais aussi
sur mon appréciation des choses au
regard de mon ex de mon expertise de de
mon expérience administrative et vous
parler à la fois de la saisine de la
justice a renvoie à l'article 40 du code
de procédure pénale vous renvoyez aussi
à l'igpn ça renvoie au droit
disciplinaire
moi je vous je vais vous donner très
sincèrement puisque vous me invité mon
sentiment de hauts fonctionnaires
qu'est ce qui se passe mais donc pour
ceux qui le savent
qu'est ce qui se passe le 2 mai il ya la
révélation parce que quelqu un l elysée
à vue a reconnu a alerté le cercle de
ceux qui savent dès le 2 mai ce qui
s'est passé les faits sont graves
le préjudice
je vais peut être vous choquer mais je
vous le dis vraiment avec beaucoup de
sincérité le préjudice lui-même ne l'est
pas je veux dire par là que les
personnes interpellées de manière
absolument irrégulière ne sont pas
blessés
elle ne portons donc d'ailleurs pas
plainte elles seront comment dire
transporté rue de l'évangile il y aura
pas de mesures de garde à vue et donc je
voudrais développer devant chers
collègues je voudrais qu'on puisse sans
entendre le directeur général je
voudrais développer devant vous la
conception que j'ai de l'application du
droit elle n'engage que moi mais c'est
une pratique courante et je le ferai sur
les deux aspects l'article 40 et la
procédure disciplinaire à partir du haut
on n'est pas la règle de droit est
écrite et l'article 40 est écrite dans
tout ça c'est serait-ce et c'est tout
fonctionnaire tout agent public qui a
connaissance du de de faits délictueux
qui a obligation de saisir le procureur
de la république tout fonctionnaire
alors j'ai vu les débats à l'assemblée
nationale notamment sur qui devait le
ministre le directeur de cabinet du
ministre directeur de cabinet de la
présidence de la république le préfet de
police le directeur de l'ordre de
la de l'ordre public et de la
circulation bref beaucoup de gens
savaient et donc en application stricte
du texte de l'article de 40 du code de
procédure pénale beaucoup de gens
étaient en situation de pouvoir le faire
le faire c'est-à-dire informer le
procureur de la république
alors on n'est pas dans un système de
deux fonctionnaires robot
qui en application d'un certain nombre
de faits appuient sur le bouton rouge ou
appuyez sur le bouton vert on regarde
effectivement la manière dont les choses
se sont passées on les contextualise et
on essaye de faire une application
intelligente du droit qu'est-ce qui se
passe encore une fois je comprends que
mes propos puisse vous choquer je vous
parle de la vraie vie et de rien d'autre
je ne vous fais pas un cours de droit
qu'est ce qui se fait ce qui se passe
non mes chers collègues ou
administratives et vous plaît qu'est-ce
qui se passe il ya des faits qui sont
extrêmement graves tout le monde les a
qualifiés qui sont inacceptables qui
sont commis par un jeune homme à mon
avis qui a un peu perdu les pédales qui
a eu on va dire un peu la grosse tête et
qui s'est senti pousser des ailes à
raison de l' administration prestigieuse
dans laquelle dans laquelle il se trouve
et dit fais ce qu'il fait et c'est
absolument condamnable que fait le
directeur de cabinet du président de la
république dès qu'il en a connaissance
il le convoque lui demande des
explications
il lui inflige une sanction
disciplinaire et permettez-moi de le
dire cette sanction disciplinaire
contrairement à ce que j'ai entendu
n'est pas une sanction clémente
ça n'est pas une suspension c'est une
mise à pied
il est contractuel il n'est pas
fonctionnaire rapporté au droit de la
fonction publique s'il avait été
fonctionnaire ça équivaudrait à une
exclusion temporaire de fonction est une
sanction du deuxième groupe qui est une
sanction grave et donc la sanction qui
est infligé à monsieur benalla n'est pas
une sanction anodine et dans la fonction
publique il aurait été fonctionnaire il
aurait sans doute
une expo pardon vous laissez pas
interrompre monsieur direct lille et il
est exclu
il est exclu de ses fonctions mais ça ne
s'arrête pas là dans la fonction
publique l'exclusion temporaire de
fonctions de 15 jours aurait été sans
doute été prononcée c'est assez
vraisemblable
elle aurait sans doute été assortie
d'une période complémentaire de sursis
d'un ou deux mois
une sorte d'épée de damoclès pédagogique
qu'on met sur la tête du fonctionnaire
pour lui dire si tu refais une bêtise
1 le sursis sera révoqué donc tu auras
deux mois de suspension en plus et tu
auras bien entendu la faute
la sanction pour la nouvelle faute qui
s'ajoutera à tous à vertus un peu
pédagogique du du sursis mais la vertu
pédagogique de la sanction qu'on
prononce monsieur strzoda existe il est
indiqué il est indiqué que à la
prochaine incartade c'est pas écrit
comme ça il sera licencié et enfin ya un
autre élément dans la dent dans la
lettre de sanction de monsieur strzoda
c'est que son périmètre fonctionnel et
modifier dans la fonction publique ça
équivaudrait à apprendre le
fonctionnaire est à lui confier d'autres
missions
ce qui ne serait pas possible dans la
fonction publique parce qu'on ne peut
pas à la fois exclure temporaire de
fonctions premières sanctions et a
ajouté une deuxième sanction qui serait
de déplacement d'office
ça n'existe pas c'est illégal donc la
sanction qui est prononcée par monsieur
strzoda est une sanction qui n'est pas
légère et y est même plus sévère que
celle qui aurait pu être
comment dire infligé un fonctionnaire
notre notamment le principe de la double
sanction dont monsieur benalla de ce que
je lis de la lettre est destinataire est
donc très honnêtement et très
sincèrement je pense que placé dans la
même situation que monsieur patrick
strzoda j'aurais pris exactement la même
décision
je le dis vraiment en toute sincérité et
je ne je ne je ne suis pas connu pour
être particulièrement léger avec
l'application du droit
je reviens pas sur les circonstances du
1er mai sauf si vous le souhaitez
simplement pour souligner que ça a été
une journée extrêmement difficile et des
phénomènes de violence que l'on n'avait
jamais connu je redis que c'est le 2 mai
dans la matinée autour de 10h 10h15 que
j'ai été alertée par un appel
téléphonique venant du palais de
l'elysée sur ce que mon interlocuteur me
désigne affaires benalla et selon la
formule je suis très étonné je ne
comprends pas je lui demande de quoi il
s'agit il m'explique les choses
l'existence de cette vidéo
j'ai joué assez vite le cabinet du
ministre de l'intérieur qui m'a indiqué
être déjà informé être en liaison avec
l'elysée
j'ai demandé évidemment mes
collaborateurs de trouver très vite
cette vidéo nous l'avons regardé
ensemble sur un grand écran dans le
bureau de mon directeur de cabinet jeudi
un grand écran parce que sur un
téléphone portable c'était petit et puis
sur le grand écran peut-être
pourrions-nous reconnaître monsieur
monsieur benalla ce qui n'était pas du
tout évident et ça ça se passe donc le
le 2 mai au matin j'ai eu contact aussi
après avoir prévenu le cabinet du
ministre de nouveau avec le palais de
l'elysée pour expliquer les
les choses telles que je les avais vus à
l'écran et il était clair pour moi que
le dossier était pris en compte par ce
que j'appelle l'autorité hiérarchique
monsieur benalla était sous la
responsabilité de l'autorité
hiérarchique du directeur de cabinet de
la présidence et non pas de moi même mes
réactions en interne pour faire vite je
demande immédiatement à la direction de
l'ordre public et de la circulation
bref pourquoi et comment il était là
sachant que j'avais été très étonné la
veille au soir de croiser monsieur
benalla dans la salle de commandement où
j'avais accueilli ministre mais c'est en
faisant le tour est là étonné je fais tu
es sur le terrain voilà la réponse que
j'ai eu et très vite le direct
immédiatement le directeur de notre
public et de la circulation m'a dit je
n'étais pas informé du fait que monsieur
benalla était ce jour là dans nos rangs
y mène son enquête interne qui fait
apparaître le niveau d'organisation de
la venue de monsieur benalla
autorisation réponse à sollicitations je
ne sais pas les enquêtes en cours au
plan judiciaire le diront peut-être
c'est pourquoi je dis le niveau
d'organisation et d'accueil au niveau
d'un contrôleur général chef d'état
major adjoint qui s'appelle monsieur
simona donc il y a eu du côté de
l'elysée monsieur patrick strzoda mon
collègue ami patrick strzoda l'a dit
l'autorisation donnée par le cabinet du
président de la république à monsieur
benalla devenir le 1er mai sur le
territoire de la préfecture de police
à la préfecture de police a eu lieu au
niveau d'un contrôleur général
l'organisation de sa venue le directeur
adjoint de l'ordre public
le directeur de l'ordre public n'était
pas informé le préfet de police
encore moins voilà exactement comment
les choses se sont se sont passées pour
la connaissance de ceux de ce
déplacement
j'ai dans le menu précisé l'enchaînement
de de ces informations successives
à ce stade je ne peux en dire plus si
vous le permettez je répondrai en
revanche très volontiers à toutes les
questions qui vont suivre j'espère ne
pas avoir été trop longs et ne pas trop
avoir pris l'engagement que j'avais pris
de ce point de vue
monsieur le président messieurs le
préfet je vous remercie
la question de la plus simple qui me
vient à l'esprit est la suivante au
fonds beaucoup d'informations ont été
données sur le moment précis auquel vous
même le directeur de cabinet du ministre
le ministre le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république ont été
informés de la participation de monsieur
benalla à une opération de maintien de
l'ordre pour laquelle il était
naturellement tout à fait illégitime
qu'ils apportent un concours
nous comprenons que dès le 2 mai et
autres autorités que j'ai cités dont
vous faites partie et qui se sont
concertés en tout cas qui ont été qui
ont eu des échanges entre elles prennent
la décision de ne pas saisir
l'inspection générale de la police
nationale et de ne pas faire usage de
l'article 40 du code de procédure pénale
je veux savoir si c'est une décision à
site ou une décision concertée
la réponse de monsieur le président on
relève de la plus tôt de la catégorie de
décisions tacite il n'y a pas eu en tant
que tel de décision je vous redis de mon
point de vue comment cela a été vécu
encore une fois j'avais été alerté par
le palais de l'elysée qui j'ai fait
remonter parce que je ne pouvais analyse
et c'est donc là la surprise la
condamnation est immédiatement le palais
l'elysée m'a dit que c'était lui qui
prenait en compte si vous voulez comme
autorités responsables hiérarchiques et
pour moi il était clair que c'était à ce
niveau que ça devait se dérouler
quand l'appréciation des suites à donner
selon la formule c'est l'autorité
compétente et donc c'est ce qui m'a
guidée de manière assez simple et assez
évidente je dois le dire donc y at il eu
concertation
y at il eu ordre de ne pas utiliser
leurs 40 etc
sûrement pas sûrement pas c'est vous
pouvez l'appeler décision tacite mais il
n'y a eu aucun échange sur le thème
faut-il faut-il pas qui non non et non
c'est donc du tacite au terme des
échanges comme vous l'indiquez voilà
comment ça s'est passé
sur le fond le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république s'est exprimé
hier vous avez eu également le l'analyse
que l'igpn a fait de ce sujet
puisqu'elle avait reçu la vidéo
mais j'ajoute que pour le préfet de
police la petite nuance supplémentaires
c'est que le débordement la faute
le manquement le dérapage personnel il
n'est pas le fait d'un fonctionnaire de
police
il n'est pas le fait d'un fonctionnaire
de police
il est le fait d'un collaborateur du de
la présidence de la république et non
pas d'un personnel placé sous mon
autorité et c'est le point qui pour moi
était cardinal dans le si vous voulez la
position qui a été qui a été la mienne
parce que moi si je vois la vidéo je
vois pas la vidéo contamment je crois
nos amis de l'igpn qui ne savaient pas
qu'ils étaient les personnes
moi quand je vois la vidéo c'est pour
que je puisse confirmer oui c'est bien
monsieur b dallas que j'aurais été
incapable de reconnaître il a fallu
vraiment qu'on voit sur un grand écran
et on était plusieurs autour de moi pour
pour l'identifier mais c'est pas moi qui
l'identifié le premier puisque m'alerter
encore une fois je crois que tout le
monde l'a bien compris et partant de là
le manquement la faute et qui sera
devant a examinées par les tribunaux de
l'ordre judiciaire c'est pas un
fonctionnaire de police
c'est pas vous faire le policer l'igpn
est compétente et je saisi l'igpn pour
les gens qui sont sous mon autorité
meilleur exemple le 19 juillet je viens
la journée du 19 juillet pour vous
donner l'exemple
je rappelle que la veille au soir nous
avons été un certain nombre à être
alertés sur le fait que le journal le
monde allait comme on dit entre nous
sortir la vidéo benalla on doit prendre
cette expression familière que tout le
monde comprend je n'ai alerté le
directeur de l'ordre public j'ai refait
le point avec lui un de ses
collaborateurs le lendemain matin pour
bien se remettre en tête les faits et du
1er mai place de la contrescarpe parce
que le 1er mai pour le préfet de police
ça n'a pas été que la place de la
contrescarpe je me permets de le je me
permets de le rappeler et le lendemain
je vous le rappelle enfin en tout cas je
l'indiquent devant votre commission il
était un peu avant 14 heures lorsque
monsieur alain gibelin directeur de
l'ordre public demande à me voir sans
délai j'avais un déjeuner de travail
avec un collègue j'ai dit venez donc à
la résidence
j'ai quitté d'ailleurs la table du
déjeuner et là il me révèle avec stupeur
et un peu effondré voilà mon le
commissaire kroes a vient de me révéler
ce qu'ils ont fait hier soir avec deux
autres collègues c'est à dire récupérer
une des images un support qui avait été
pris de la scène de la contrescarpe pour
aller la porter à monsieur benalla ma
réaction est ce assez pour répondre à la
question
l'ag des fonctionnaires qui sont sous
mon autorité sous ma responsabilité est
ce que j'ai fait dans les deux heures
qui ont suivi c'est d'abord récupérer
leurs rapports écrits pour qu'ils
écrivent et pas seulement être dans le
dans l'oralité préparer la transmission
des données que je venais de recueillir
dans le cadre de l'article 40 à monsieur
le procureur de la république
j'ai personnellement appelé françois
molins ce pour le lui dire et dans le
même temps que je saisissais le
procureur de la république saisir le
ministre de l'intérieur le niveau
central et j'ai eu un échange au
téléphone avec monsieur gérard collomb
lui-même pour lui demander la suspension
immédiate de ces trois fonctionnaires et
ça a été fait dans la soirée les trois
fonctionnaires ont déposés ont déposé
leurs armes vous l'avez fait d'ailleurs
voisin pour pour un d'entre eux et deux
autres c'est le directeur de l'autre
public qu'il a fait ça a été fait
immédiatement mais c'étaient des
fonctionnaires là sous mon autorité et
c'était à moi et à personne d'autre de
prendre cette initiative
voilà vraiment le choix qui a été le
mien et comme je les dis ailleurs c'est
un choix qui m'a conduit ce jour là et
le 2 mai et le 19 juillet si je puis
dire est que je vous expose la dans la
plus totale clarté et honnêteté et
choses sont très claires pour le 19
juillet mais permettez-moi de revenir
sur le 2 mai monsieur le préfet il y à
la faute de monsieur vénale à tout le
monde en parle
il y a aussi les conditions de la faute
elles lui ont été offertes par le
service
il y as sans doute la faute du cadre
dirigeant de la préfecture de police qui
en dehors de l'exercice de ses
compétences et de la délégation dont il
peut avoir bénéficié accorde la
possibilité à monsieur benalla d'être
accompagné par un autre fonctionnaire
pour assister aux opérations de maintien
de l'ordre que la sanction disciplinaire
infligée à monsieur benalla n'ai pu lui
être infligée que par le directeur de
cabinet du président de la république la
cause est entendue
mais monsieur simona qui je crois est
celui que vous visitiez quand vous
parliez de copinage malsain c'est comme
ça que nous n'avons interpréter car il
s'agissait sans doute de sa relation
avec monsieur benalla que vous mettiez
en cause n'est pas lui même fait l'objet
de poursuites disciplinaires que
l'inspection générale de la police
nationale pour ce qui concernait
d'éventuels dysfonctionnements de
l'administration de la police n'ait pas
été saisie reste pour moi une question
du point de vue du bon fonctionnement de
l'état et je veux vous la poser
je vais vous répondre bien sûr j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire d'ailleurs mais je
vous le redis ici
si la demande m'avait été soumises
ce qui n'a pas été le cas je ne l'aurais
pas refuser je voulais dit en
introduction une collaborateur du chef
de l'état autorisé par sa hiérarchie qui
souhaitent venir à la préfecture de
police je n'aurais pas dit non j'aurais
dit oui et sans aucun doute j'aurais
veiller à l'encadrement dans des
conditions autres sans doute en mettant
d'ailleurs auprès de lui j'ai envie de
dire en le recevant mieux d'ailleurs en
mettant auprès de lui un cadre de deux
plus hauts de plus haut niveau mais sur
le fait de l'accueillir
je suis désolé en soi l'accueillir n'est
pas une faute
et si monsieur simoneau a commis une
faute c'est pas de l'accueillir
c'est de ne pas en rendre compte à sa
hiérarchie et de cela il lui a été fait
les reproches qui convenait sous forme
d'admonestation verbal par son directeur
c'est un défaut de rendre compte alors
c'est un défaut de rendre compte en
temps donc c'est grave mais ce n'est
qu'un défaut de rendre compte
la faute c'est pas c'est pas d'avoir
accueilli c'est d'avoir organisé
l'accueil sans que son directeur été
informé ni le préfet de police
tom défaut de rendre de rendre compte un
défaut de loyauté hiérarchique est
évidemment moi j'ai demandé au directeur
de l'ordre public de faire à monsieur
simonin sur ce sujet des représentations
sévère sous formes de monnaies station
qui convenait mais on ne pouvait pas
aller sur un terrain disciplinaire au
dollar
comme toujours la faute et la réponse de
la faute
quelle est la faute c'est celle là c'est
pas le fait de lui avoir dit oui venez
c'est le fait d'avoir dit oui venez sans
que sa hiérarchie est tt était prévenue
voilà vraiment la situation
vous parlez du contrôleur général simon
hayes permettez moi de dire un mot
j'étais sans faiblesse vous le savez le
19 juillet mais la grave faute là qu'il
a commis le 18 juillet au soir avec deux
autres collègues ça c'est une grave
faute que d'être allé chercher de la
vidéo pour l'amener à monsieur b dallas
j'ai dit ma réaction tout à l'heure mais
cette grave faute n'enlèvera rien les
mérites qu'il a eu par ailleurs vous
savez c'est un peu comme un grand
footballeur il peut avoir marqué trois
buts lors d'un match formidable mais si
deux mois après il commet quelque chose
de dramatique
besset l'un et c'est l'autre et si vous
vous souvenez faut voir le printemps
qu'on a traversé les interventions
milieu universitaire évacuation de la
sorbonne aucune difficulté j'ai suivi ça
en direct avec les images aucune
violence
aucun pépin aucune plainte évacuation de
tolbiac
on voulait pas me croire quand j'ai fait
un communiqué à 6h30 du matin pour dire
que tout s'était bien passé et que
c'était fini qui commandait les troupes
qui est allé c'était le contrôleur
général simonin donc c'est un
professionnel aguerri et je ne peux pas
effacer ses mérites
je les rappelle devant vous tout en
soulignant par ailleurs la gravité à mes
yeux de la faute qu'il a commise et
c'est là où j'ai évoqué le copinage
malsain mais la formule a été reprise
pourquoi c'est à dire que une peste de
facilité dans ce copinage malsain qui
fait qu' on pense qu'on peut comme ça en
oubliant un petit peu les règles
hiérarchiques et les principes organiser
d organiser des choses mais le copinage
malsain
on verra ce que dit la justice quand
elles auront connaître si elle vient sur
ce terrain là c'était pas non plus de
quoi de quoi aller au-delà de ce que
j'ai fait en sa direction c'est-à-dire
d'augmenter au directeur de l'ordre
public de lui faire les représentations
qui convenait et de le faire sous forme
d'admonestation verbale ça a été fait
merci monsieur le préfet monsieur le
rapporteur
merci monsieur le
le président monsieur le préfet nous
connaissons votre professionnalisme
celui de vos collègues que vous avez
évoquées et nous ne nous ne
méconnaissons pas la dureté de la tâche
vous avez cité et dans une journée comme
celle du premier mais c'est vrai que la
gestion de tout cela n'est pas du tout
facile je me dois cependant de vous
poser des questions très précises
je vends posé trois pour éclairer la
commission et pour établir des faits
prennent la première question porte sur
le port d'armes de monsieur benalla vous
avez indiqué devant la commission des
lois de l'assemblée nationale avoir
accordé un permis de port d'armes à
monsieur benalla en octobre 2017
alors je vous cite qu'il ne remplissait
pas les conditions réglementaires pour
disposer d'une arme
monsieur le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république a déclaré e
devant l'assemblée nationale qu'il avait
qu'il vous avait demandé lui même qu'il
y est un port d'armes attribuée à
monsieur benalla qu'il vous l'avez
demandé
mais en précisant je cite sous réserve
que cette autorisation puisse être
accordée dans le strict respect des
textes
or il est clair que cette autorisation
de port d'armes a été attribué dans des
conditions qui ne sont pas le strict
respect des textes
donc c'est ma première interrogation
monsieur le préfet je peux répondre
maintenant bien sûr si préfet s'il vous
plaît je réponds je réponds sur ce point
vous faites dire un quelque chose alors
j'ai pas vu le verbatim qui n'est pas en
tout cas conforme à ce que j'ai à ce que
j'ai déclaré enfin je verrai le verbatim
peut-être cette formule ne s'y trouve
mais je vais essayer là aussi
d'expliquer de quoi il s'agit on est
dans un cadre juridique assez complexe
qu'est celui du port d'armes
en fait vous avez deux régimes très
différents et aux finalités très
différentes et il ya sans doute parfois
des confusions
vous avez un premier régime juridique du
port d'armes qui relève de la compétence
du ministre de l'intérieur
la finalité je vais vous citer l'article
r 300 15-5 est la suivante le ministre
de l'intérieur peut autoriser par
arrêter toute personne exposée à des
risques exceptionnels d'atteinte à sa
vie je dis bien des risques
exceptionnels de l'atteinte à sa vie sur
sa demande à apporter transporter une
arme de poing
la demande que monsieur benalla avait
formulées sur ce plan et dont d'ailleurs
je n'avais pas eu connaissance et
j'avais pas en avoir connaissance
puisqu'elle était du niveau ministériel
a été refusée a été refusé parce qu'il a
été apprécié à mon avis justement
apprécié que monsieur benalla n'était
pas une personne exposée à des risques
exceptionnels d'atteinte à sa vie
monsieur benalla a présenté ensuite à
l'autorité préfectorale que je suis une
demande qui est sur un autre fondement
l'autre fondement je cite le texte de
loi c les fonctionnaires ou agents des
administrations publiques exposé par
leurs fonctions à des risques
d'agression et dans ce cadre-là l'elysée
niveau de patrick strzoda a relayé la
demande
au regard des fonctions qu'exerçait
monsieur benalla à la présidence de la
république
donc on est sur un cadre juridique qui
n'a rien à voir avec le port d'armes
pour risques exceptionnels d'atteinte à
la vie on est sur un autre cadre
juridique et c'est dans ce cadre
juridique que j'ai donné l'autorisation
après l'instruction habituel en
recueillant le casier b2 et c
tous les éléments qui était nécessaire
pour donner cette autorisation
la petite nuance mais comme je l'étais
je vais le redire là et que j'assume est
la suivante on renvoie ensuite à des
textes réglementaires qui disait un
arrêté ministériel qui définit les
services ou catégories de services
désignant ou accueillant les
fonctionnaires et agents le la situation
était particulière puisque l'elysée ne
figurait pas dans ces catégories de
services
mais compte tenu du fait que la demande
mme été relayé en disant bien que
c'était pour ses fonctions à l'elysée
oui j'ai accepté de le délivrer dans ce
cadre là mais j'insiste beaucoup sur la
différence parce que ça n'a rien à voir
donc j'ai pas substituer ma décision à
la précédente
je vais même vous dire et je citerai pas
des cas mais je connais certaines
situations en tout cas oui j'en connais
où on a donné autorisation
en fait pour l'exercice de certaines
missions en se fondant sur le niveau
central des risques exceptionnels
d'atteinte à la vie alors que je ne
pense pas que ce soit ce soit le cas
donc là dessus qu'on soit bien clair on
était dans une compet une compétence
préfectoral donc que j'ai que j'ai
assumée normalement c'est mon devoir de
l'assumer et évidemment aussi lorsque la
mission de monsieur benalla a cessé j'ai
immédiatement abrogé l'autorisation que
j'avais donnée elle était strictement
est uniquement liée à ses fonctions
ce qui veut dire aussi moi je sais pas
ce que l' enquête établira ce qui veut
dire aussi que s'il avait son arme
ce jour là lorsqu'il était place de la
contrescarpe
il était en faute il n'avait absolument
pas à l'avoir vu ce qu'il était hors des
fonctions et en jours de congé donc pour
moi là dessus on verra mois sur les
images il ne semble pas avoir vu mais
c'est pas moi d'apprécier
c'est le juge qui dira encore une fois
c'est une le cadre juridique c'est les
cetc le cadre juridique par exemple qui
s'applique pour les transporteurs de
fonds pour donner un exemple concret
liée à l'exercice des fonctions et
compte tenu des fonctions qui étaient
allés disait telles qu'elles ont été
rapportées
oui j'ai pressé j'ai pris cette décision
avec cette nuance ce que j'ai peut-être
évoqué au regard du cadre réglementaire
qu'il n'y avait pas dans l'arrêté
ministériel
la citation de l'elysée mais ce qui
n'est pas étonnant en revanche il y
avait l'affirmation de l'elysée mais je
confirme aussi que mon collègue annie
patrick strzoda me l'a transmis en dix
ans dans le respect des textes bien sûr
moi je n'ai eu comme préfet de police
aucune remontée de la part de mes
services je dis bien aucune sur une
situation au cours de laquelle monsieur
benalla aurait par son comportement
perturbé ou mis en péril ou gêner le
fonctionnement de notre institution je
n'ai eu aucune remontée
j'entends ça ces jours ci je peux vous
affirmer qu'il n'y en a eu aucune signe
en avait une
j'aurais sans doute connaissant mon
tempérament effectivement alerté le
directeur de cabinet en disant coup de
patrick peut-être fait attention minyana
eu aucune
et je vais pas raconter des histoires
après coup pour essayer de d'embellir la
réalité la défense de monsieur ben alla
invoque l'article 73 du code de
procédure pénale qui permet à tout
citoyen d'intervenir sur un flagrant
délit
est ce que en l'état actuel de vos
connaissances et les personnes
interpellées pensionnat la mise à
disposition d'un officier de police
judiciaire avaient étaient en train de
commettre ou avait immédiatement commis
des délits d'outragé de rébellion ou de
violences sur agents de 2 deuxième
question vous avez beaucoup parlé du
statut d observateur quel est le statut
des fonctionnaires d'autorité qui
parfois interviennent où sont présents
sur une opération de police
on les reconnaît quand c'est des membres
du corps préfectoral mais lorsqu'il
s'agit de collaborateurs de cabinets
ministériels ou de dévises et qu'on voit
parfois donné des directives pour nous
hors précis aux agents des forces de
l'ordre quel est leur statut exact et
peut-il à ce moment là monsieur vidal
avoir le statut de collaborateur
occasionnel est relevé à ce moment-là de
est ce que les collaborateurs
occasionnels peuvent relever de votre
compétence troisième et dernière
question on les syndicats de police ont
dénoncé des dysfonctionnements créée par
monsieur benalla au sein du gspr le gspr
peut-il relevé de votre compétence
madame la directrice oui monsieur le
président monsieur le sénateur
s'agissant donc de l'article 73 du code
de procédure pénale effectivement la
défense de monsieur benalla était de
dire qu'il avait aidé les services de
police il appartiendra à lenquête
judiciaire de dire si oui ou non les
fonctionnaires de police qui était sur
la place avait besoin d' aide en tant
que chef de l'inspection qui a vu les
images je suis pas convaincu mais encore
une fois
là on est dans l' enquête judiciaire et
je vais avoir du mal à en dire davantage
s'agissant du statut des fonctionnaires
d'autorité qui interviennent lors de
service d'ordre
moi je rappelle toujours la règle je
suis le chef de l'inspection générale
donc je rappelle la règle
la règle c'est que le responsable sur le
terrain c'est le chef du dispositif est
au dessus de lui
l'autorité préfectorale à partir de ce
moment là c'est à eux de dire ce qu'il
faut faire c'est à eux de donner les
ordres de donner les instructions et de
d'assumer toutes leurs responsabilités
s'agissant des de ce que disent
aujourd'hui les syndicats sur les
dysfonctionnements au sein du gspr
je n'en ai pas connaissance je n'avais
jamais entendu parler de monsieur
benalla avant le 19 juillet et j'ai
jamais eu de syndicats ou d'autres
personnes d'ailleurs qui nous est dit
que sur le terrain où ailleurs il ya eu
des difficultés avec monsieur benalla
bien peut-être que spontanément on vient
parfaire ce genre de 2,2
de confidences à l'inspection générale
d'enfants en tout cas objectivement est
factuellement je n'ai jamais rien eu de
tout cela la compétence alors la
compétence de l'igpn sur les agents du
svr ne s'appliquerait qu'aux policiers
donc vous êtes compétentes faites votre
réflexion est compétente pour examiner
le comportement de policiers servant
cessa regroupement de de sécurité de la
présidence de la république c'est très
important de le savoir
je vous remercie et je donne la parole à
monsieur à la marque
merci monsieur le président il m'a
semblé dans vos propos que vous vous
étonnez que l'article 40 n'est pas été
activée nous aussi puisque beaucoup de
gens quittent est dépositaire de
l'autorité publique ne l'ont pas fait et
c'est vrai que c'est assez étonnant
ensuite je voudrais savoir si vous
trouvez normal la motivation de monsieur
mais n'a à qui on avait décerné le grade
de lieutenant-colonel au titre de la
réserve qui ensuite vient comme
observateurs voient pour moi il ya une
contradiction j'aimerais savoir ce que
vous en pensez
madame la directrice
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur je ne me suis pas étonné j'ai
rappelé la règle j'ai rappelé la loi
pour l'artiste agissante de l'article 40
mon rôle n'est pas de m'étonner pas
m'étonner
mon rôle c'est de voir la loi les faits
et l'environnement s'agissant du de
monsieur belal nos collègues et au titre
de la réserve qui a besoin si je
comprends bien votre question qui a
besoin quand même d'aller comme
observateur pour pour pour ressentir les
choses et acquérir de l'expérience
enfin justement il ya quand même une
contradiction entre le fait que cette
personne on lui décerner le titre de
lieutenant colonel
avec spécialités sécurité qu'ils aient
besoin de se rendre comme observateurs
si ce n'est un excuse et moi peut-être
d'autres motivations que peut-être plus
que celle d'un simple observateur il
doit connaître normalement je je je vais
avoir un petit peu de mal à répondre à
votre question mais je le sénateur
je tiens personnellement je j'ai
travaillé pendant quelques années à la
formation de la police nationale et je
défends des la formation continue et
considérant qu' on avait toujours besoin
de ceux de se perfectionner et d'en
apprendre plus donc je ne suis pas
psychologue je n'ai pas je n'ai pas de
jets pas de compétence pour dire ce que
monsieur benalla souhaitez vous ne
souhaitez pas j'en reste encore une fois
au fait et ça ne me choque pas que
quelqu'un ait et ai envie d'en apprendre
davantage merci madame madame benbassa
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
enfin vous avez parlé de des
observateurs et ne pensez vous pas après
cette affaire banale a même si vous
n'avez pas eu jusque là des problèmes
avec des observateurs qu'il faudrait les
encadrer davantage la fonction tout en
tout temps là me directrice oui monsieur
le président madame la sénatrice
évidemment encore une fois comme je le
disais dans mon propos liminaire on nous
n'avons jamais eu de problème
et pourtant les observateurs surnombre
les stagiaires sont nombreux y compris
encore une fois dans des structures qui
étaient relativement fermé comme
l'inspection générale cette affaire va
évidemment nous amener essais et c'est
l'objet de l'étude qui a été demandé par
le ministre va évidemment nous amener à
proposer un certain nombre d'éléments de
cadrage pour les observateurs pour
autant pour autant
il faudra laisser de la marge de
manoeuvre aux chefs de service sur le
terrain parce qu'encore une fois tous
les observateurs ne sont pas de même
niveau
tous les observateurs ne viennent pas
avec les mêmes demandes tous les
observateurs ne restent pas
la même durée et et toutes les
situations ne n'ont pas la même
sensibilité
donc il nous faudra apporter un cadre
qui soit structurant un cadre qui soit
aussi comment dire protecteur un pour
les fonctionnaires de police et je pense
notamment à ceux qui accompagnent
l'observateur on en a l'expérience la
avec avec cette affaire mais il faudra
laisser de la place à
l'adaptation un os situation et de la
place à ce que j'ai envie de dire relève
simplement du bon sens et du
discernement mais on peut penser que
l'ajout de nouvelles règles n'est pas
forcément la meilleure parade contre
ceux qui violent les règles ya un
problème d'une nature un peu différente
aussi qui est soulevée alors madame di
folco merci monsieur le président et
peut-être ma question s'adresse-t-elle
d'ailleurs à monsieur michelin vous
verrez en réalité monsieur michelin n'a
pas prêté serment mais mais alors merci
si vous souhaitez qu'il s'exprime je le
ferais prêter serment alors vous verrez
donc en fait ma question est dans le
prolongement de celle de monsieur marc
en réalité moi j'aurais bien aimé savoir
pourquoi ou qui a demandé à monsieur
benalla d'être observateur ce jour là le
1er mai sur cette manifestation ça me
paraît intéressante elle de savoir quel
est le motif qui a été invoqué par
monsieur benalla pour être accrédités à
être observateur
alors peut-être est-ce dans le cadre de
votre enquête sur l'accueil des
observateurs que vous pourriez avoir ce
renseignement puisque je l' ai demandé à
monsieur le directeur de la police
nationale
il n'est pas au courant monsieur morvan
il n'est pas au courant c'est passé
services etc
donc j'aimerais bien savoir qui donne
l'habilitation et quel était le motif
demandé ça me paraît important de savoir
pourquoi ou qui a demandé à monsieur
benalla d'être observateur
est ce que votre rapport répondra bien à
cette question madame alors répondre à
bien à cette question mais enquête
judiciaire et une enquête administrative
ça c'est clair parce que justement on va
pouvoir poser ces questions vous êtes au
centre du sujet bien on va pouvoir poser
ces questions à l'ensemble des acteurs
et ça a déjà démarré d'ailleurs dans l'
enquête dans mon enquête judiciaire
on a un sujet c'est que il n'y a pas de
demande écrite
il n'y a pas de réponse écrite
ça se fait de gré à gré et s'est pas
complètement
enfin incompréhensible ce genre ce genre
de choses je peux vous donner quelques
éléments mais qui sont les éléments qui
ont été fournis dans l' enquête
administrative c'est qu'en fait la
demande
elle est faite par monsieur benalla
celui qui souhaite être observateur et à
partir de cela à partir de cette demande
les les versions sont un petit peu un
petit peu différente
je crois que
je crois que certains ont pu croire que
les accords avaient été donnés alors que
les accords ne l'ont pas été 1 et que
les accords ont été donnés mais pas au
bon niveau hiérarchique
voilà mais encore une fois l'enquète
judiciaire ira plus loin alors que le
directeur général de la police nationale
ne vous ai pas répondu sur ce point est
tout à fait normal directeur général de
la police nationale n'est pas préfet de
police ce n'est pas lui qui a autorité
sur ce qui se passe à paris c'est
évidemment pas lui qui a reçu la demande
ou aurait dû recevoir à recevoir la
demande il peut effectivement pas vous
répondre ça n'est pas je pense de la
mauvaise volonté de sa part c'est tout
simplement qu' il n'est pas il n'est pas
compétent au sens juridique du terme
dans ce sujet madame delattre c'est la
dernière question parfait merci monsieur
le président madame la directrice je
voudrais d'abord vous remercier d'un
quartier de vos propos dans les
compétences qui sont les vôtres et dans
les limites de l enquête judiciaire bien
évidemment alors moi pour bien
comprendre effectivement vous êtes
saisis parce que il ya des vidéos qui
vous remonte donc vous pensez
effectivement que vous avez à faire vos
services pense qu'ils ont à faire
un policier qui exercent et qui a des
gestes techniques professionnelles qui
sont pour le moins limite c'est-à-dire
qui effectivement ne sont pas très
professionnel et en fait il ne se passe
rien c'est à dire qu'il n'ya pas de
dents vie de savoir de la part de vos
services de qui il s'agit pour pouvoir
lui dire qu'effectivement son geste ces
gestes ne sont pas professionnels qu'il
faut peut-être qu'ils repartent en
formation c'est à dire qu'en fait là
vous estimez qu'effectivement c'est une
situation très délicate
donc il est dans le cadre ce policier
est dans le cadre de ses fonctions avec
des gestes
limite mais vous n'allez pas plus loin
c'est à dire que effectivement il n'ya
pas de recherche de qui est ce policier
du coup vous la faire benalla vous
revient ultérieurement
mais pour vous en mais ça s'arrête là
dire que si c'est un policier ça ne va
pas plus loin
et là on revient parce qu'on s'aperçoit
que c'est pas un policier et on trouve
que les gestes sont plus que déplacé
mais moi ce qui m'interpelle c'est ça
c'est qu'il n'y a pas eu de volonté
à un moment donné de savoir quelle est
cette personne qui a ses gestes déplacés
alors c'est presque un commentaire en
même temps qu'une question madame la
directrice
voilà notre collègue s'étonne que les
violences commises qui ne pourraient pas
relever d'un professionnel de son point
de vue n'est pas immédiatement
puisqu'elle avait été signalé sur la
plate forme même s'il ya beaucoup
signalement sur la plateforme entraîné
de votre part de réaction et que la
seule justification de la saisine de
l'inspection générale c'est qu'il
s'agissait pas d'un fonctionnaire de
police
monsieur le président au même la
sénatrice je vais vous donner quelques
quelques éléments complémentaires sur
sur cette affaire d'abord il faut bien
comprendre que le sujet c'est pas un
sujet de violence le sujet c'est un
sujet d'usagé de la force dans des
conditions qui sont des conditions
légales de maintien de l'ordre
voilà donc juridiquement lusage de la
force est légitime à partir de ce moment
là l'usagé de la force étant légitime
pour les forces de police tout ce que
j'observe au moins c'est que les gt pays
sont pas merveilleusement maîtrisé mais
nous n'avons pas de blessure nous
n'avons pas de plaignant
nous n'avons pas de d'éléments
complémentaires nous n'avons que ça
alors nous n'avons pas pour habitude de
considérer que l' usage de la force et
illégitimes par nature au contraire
l'usagé de la force pour les services
police il est légitime par nature il ya
quelques temps je suis passé à la radio
avec des interrogations de la part
d'enfants
1 c'est sûr souffrance station d'envoi
de dire sur france culture et la
première question que m'a posé une
petite fille qui devait avoir une
dizaine d'années c'est est ce que les
policiers ils ont deux le droit de taper
les gens et ma réponse a été oui oui
parce que l' usage de la force
c'est justement la prérogative de la
police nationale de la gendarmerie
nationale des forces de sécurité mais
pas n'importe comment ça a été ma
deuxième phrase mais pas n'importe
comment il faut naturellement que les
conditions sur les conditions légales et
que la force soit proportionnée
là on a les conditions légales en allait
conditionner galles et on a de la force
qui est proportionné puisque par
définition il n'y a pas de blessure donc
à partir de ce moment là sachant que ce
jour là il ya eu 300 interpellations 300
interpellations
à partir de ce moment-là nous
considérons qu'en l'état nous n'avons
pas un témoin direct nous avons
quelqu'un qui nous envoie juste la vidéo
on a rien de plus on ne va pas classé
contrairement à ce que j'ai entendu on
ne va pas classés on va mettre cette
vidéo de côté et elle a été vu par 3
personnes
trois personnes donc pour vous prouver
que c'est pas juste un fonctionnaire qui
balaye cette affaire là on a été vu par
3 personnes c'est pour ça que je vous
dis entre le 5 et le 7 qui ont toutes
dit c'est pas génial hein comme
permettez moi l'expression c'est pas
magnifique comme j'étais pays mais bon
voilà et sans éléments complémentaires
on va mettre cette affaire de côté et on
attend les éléments complémentaires
quand vous observez les photographies et
les vidéos montrant dans un déplacement
public monsieur alexandre benalla à
proximité du président de la république
avec l' expertise qui est la vôtre
interprétez vous ces images comme le
signe qu'il accomplissait
une fonction de protection rapprochée du
président de la république pour être
tout à fait exact
j'ai vu des images bien sûr de monsieur
bénard d'un abus de large
vous savez le mieux la sécurité
rapprochée c'est un milieu complexe
ils sont rentrés dans les détails on
parle de deux cercles de responsabilité
le siècle le plus proche de la
personnalité dont on a assuré la
protection est prise en compte par le
groupe le j'espère pour le président la
république
après on a affaire à des cercles qui
s'éloigne de plus en plus qui sont pris
en compte pas d'autres services de
police et qui constitue un filtre avant
d'arriver jusqu'au président la
république dans le cercle le plus proche
le métier tels que j'ai eu à l'exercer
par le passé fait qu'on y retrouve bien
sûr d'autres personnes que le président
la république sinon il serait totalement
isolé des gens à qui souhaite rencontrer
qui souhaitent avoir un échange mais on
y rencontre également des conseillers
qui ont par leur rôle à avoir une
proximité avec le président de la
république
depuis on y rencontre également des gens
qui fit quelques longs que l'on retrouve
tels que le préfet territorialement
compétent lorsqu'ils accueillent le
président ou l'ambassadeur lorsqu'on est
l'ambassadeur de france lorsqu'on est à
l'étranger et il c'est vrai que la
sécurité rapprochée doit composer avec
ces personnes qui rentrent dans ce
cercle
quand je vois l'image du président
macron avec monsieur pénale à proximité
il m'est difficile de dire s'il est
présent à ses côtés en tant que membre
de son cabinet ou membres de sa sécurité
pour pouvoir vous répondre
il faudrait que une une action se
déroule à savoir qu'il faille opérer une
évacuation du président de la république
pour voir à ce moment là qu'ils
agiraient et que ferais tu il
aujourd'hui
la présence à proximité immédiate du
président de la république d'un certain
nombre de passes de personne ne peut pas
déterminer un coup sur son rôle
je vous ai cité toutes les personnes qui
prouve qu'on pouvait trouver dans
l'environnement immédiat du président la
république qui rentre dans le cercle que
j'ai évoqués on y trouve aussi ce que
j'appelle moi des parasites des gens qui
sont des courtisans
trouve à proximité de président de la
république est qu eux constitue une gêne
qui nous appartient de vaincus et
parfois d'éloigner pour pouvoir exercer
cette fonction
donc aujourd'hui je ne ne peux pas dire
sans qu'il y ait eu une réaction du
groupe de sécurité du président de la
république quel aurait été son rôle
on a des gens qui sont dans ce cercle
pour leur mission de sécurité rapprochée
d'autres pour leur mission de conseiller
au cabinet d'autres pour des missions de
représentation et puis d'autres des
membres de la population qui sont là
pour pouvoir s'adresser au président de
la république donc au premier regard il
est difficile d'identifier qui fait quoi
encore une fois il aurait fallu que une
action dramatique se déroule pour pour
en connaître pour connaître le rôle de
chacun lorsque vous étiez en poste à
l'élysée avez vous eu connaissance que
d'autres personnes que les membres du
commandement militaire et les membres du
gspr de disposer d'un et disposer d'un
port d'armes se ménage non bien sûr
jamais eu connaissance de ce type de
faits toutes les années où vous habitez
en fonction vous avez eu connaissance
d'aucun or d'armes pour aucune personne
quelle qu'elle soit
appartenant au personnel de l'elysée au
cabinet en dehors bien sûr de du
j'espère et du commandement militaire
non non non encore une fois ci menace
avait pesé sur un conseiller plutôt que
de lui attribuer une arme on lui
réattribuer une sécurité si vous aviez
constater qu'un collaborateur ou
quelqu'un qui est proche président lors
de ce déplacement
porter une arme auriez-vous par ses
objectifs prévenu votre ministre de
tutelle le miz l'intérieur à titre
personnel
alors monsieur le préfet même si j'avais
constaté qu' une personne était porteuse
une heure alors que à mon sens il n'y en
avait pas le rôle je n'en n'aurai pas
rendu compte
j'aurai effectué un contrôle je pense
que j'aurai interpellé la personne ou
demander aux forces locales de vérifier
pourquoi cet individu était porteur
d'une arme
clairement parce que pour moi armes
égales forces de sécurité intérieure ça
s'arrête là donc si c'est un individu
que je ne connais pas je le fais contre
lui parce que potentiellement pour moi
il est une menace si c'est un individu
que je connais je je vais m'en étonner
et je vais je pense qu'on aura une
explication
oui parce que la question de monsieur
wattebled du président en déplacement et
en tant que responsable ce que le
président quelqu'un qui a une âme de et
on le sait on le voit votre rôle
législatif là c'est pas dans le cas
actuel
auriez-vous prévenu l'autorité pour au
moins que ça se sache
bref vous seriez vous opposer à ce qu'un
collaborateur du président de la
république
la compagne en déplacement avec une arme
[Musique]
je m'en serais étonné je pense pas que
je me serais adressé aux mines de
l'intérieur je pense pas que ce soit du
niveau 2 de sa responsabilité je vais
m'en serais ouvert au chef de cabinet
directeur de cabinet au secrétaire
général de la présidence de la
république ça me semble plus adapté
n'ayant jamais été confronté à cette
situation je peux pas vous en dire
davantage mais voilà
c'est pas une situation à laquelle j'ai
été confronté lors des déplacements
privés il ya t'il systématiquement ou
bien avait-il puisque dans votre
expérience systématiquement un membre de
la chefferie de cabinet auprès du
président oui systématiquement soit le
chef de cabinet ce soit son adjoint sur
les déplacements officiels il y avait
privé vous avez alors sur les
déplacements officiels systématiquement
sur les déplacements privés très
exceptionnellement je vous remercie
madame marie pierre de la gontrie
si président monsieur le préfet ma
question est simple quelques
connaissances avez-vous aujourd'hui des
fonctions réelles qu'occupait monsieur
benalla ce préfet alors je vais parler
de mes fonctions après le j'espère après
le j'espère je les dis dans ma
présentation j'étais chef de l'unité de
coordination des grands événements au
cabinet du directeur général de la
police nationale et j'ai rencontré
monsieur benalla à l'occasion de
l'organisation du sommet de décembre
ce mec s'est déroulée sur l'île seguin
sommet pour le financement des actions
de la cote climat pour eux pour faire un
raccourci
ce sommet a rassemblé une quarantaine de
chefs d'état du étrangers et donc en ma
qualité de d'experts dans l'organisation
pour la sécurité des grands événements g
j'ai eu à rencontrer monsieur bnl à
cette occasion il était le représentant
de la présidence de la république pour
l'organisation de ce sommet il a dirigé
plusieurs réunions la auquel j'ai
assisté en tant qu'adjoint au chef du
chef de cabinet ou chargés de mission je
ne sais pas exactement mieux tout comme
adjoint du chef de cabinet et nous j'ai
fait des missions de reconnaissance sur
l'île seguin sur le bateau mouche qui
ont utilisé les chefs d'état pour se
rendre sur cette île à ses côtés et son
positionnement était clairement celui du
chef de cabinet du président le chef de
cabinet adjoint du président de la
république
[Musique]